the morning so what you want to do what
you want to do I got a pocket full of R
rubbers in my homeboy
do so crack out the lights and close the
door but for what we don't know those
hoes do that feel good I got to put a
drop some M here tomorrow my ear
swelling up this show is brought to you
by Club W that's right
go to clubw docomo now to get $20 off of
your first order that's clubw docomo to
get $20 off of your first order and it
gets even better if you hate paying for
shipping Club W understands and will pay
for your shipping on orders of four
bottles or more if you pay that's right
if you get four bottles or more at Club
w.com Joey you're going to get $20 off
of your first order and Club W is going
to pay for your shipping
go to on it.com and use cob Church to
save 10% on to save 10% on all their
great optimization products like Alpa
brain numu TR Tech immune and TR Tech
sport oh
[__] give me some bubble gum in this
[__] it's Monday May 22nd or
something like that wash your [__]
scrub your feet Jesus is coming to town
[__] JZ Palos
here yeah I wash my feet and I wash my
puss oh
[Music]
[__] break down [__] what
what
it on they Ain leaving till 6 in the
morning so what you want to
do the Church of What's Happening Now
what we don't love them hoes
yeah G's up hoes down with you
[__] what this is it
[__] kick that
muie laid back with my mind my money and
my money on my mind rolling down the
street talking in anding
on laid back my
[Music]
mind take that [__] that time the
church is what's happening now you bad
[__] it's a beautiful Monday
night to be alive jessame Palo in studio
my favorite [__] Jewish person in the
world Lisa at hey mushrooms Edibles we
we don't give a [__] here on the church
what's the story jez may talk to me I'm
just looking at how fresh and green this
[__] looks oh this [__] is tremendous
tremendous Reef I look like like a golf
like a golf course yeah no this is some
tremendous [__] weed one thing
here I take my weed seriously yeah where
you said you stopped over where
perennial oh that's right perennial
perennial got some good I get the top
shelf [__] I go in there the two top
shelf is they give you to you in the
glass tubes yeah that's and they have
everything else and they have everything
else they got nice weed there I go there
I go to Sunset heral they got some
[__] good looking Reef for that dog
oh yeah oh my God I took some a Girl
Scout thin mint cookies oh [__] I love
edibles no no no this was reefa oh [__]
that was [__] dark and oh it's called
Girl Scout thing I'm like I love cookies
Mickey Mouse that's kicking and they got
[__] exclusive that's kicking they
you [__] around over there I love I
do love edibles though you like Edibles
come on I live my main my little [__]
edible is it your brunch yeah I got a
brownie here I don't know how old it is
I don't [__] you up it'll take you into
the next Dimension it's amazing the the
edible what's happened with Edibles like
how many [__] people come up to me
and they go you know what I stop smoking
yeah I'm saving my lungs I'm just going
to [__] eat Edibles it took me a
while to get adjusted to them you know
because they give you a weird feeling it
creeps up on you weird yeah it's like a
fuzzy feeling really I like it's like
someone just asked me someone said they
were new to edible to was to marijuana
and they said well what strains do smoke
and I said honestly just start just do
Edibles I I love it I like it way better
unless it's like I want to be high for
30 minutes yeah and Ed's like that high
is a full
body sorry full body high it [__] you
up for a while it [__] you up this
times I catch myself in the living room
I'm [__] hammered hammer and my wife
knows I'm [__] hammered in the living
room like point to drooling like she's
telling me Joe go to bed Joe go to bed
and I'm ham it it feels good though and
you wake up in the middle of the night
you still ham it to pee that's the
[__] clinker sometimes you wake up
middle of the night what about the next
morning when you wake up morning and
you're and for me it doesn't hit right
away like like if I'm in bed I'm okay
but then as soon as I start walking
around I'm like you feel it that much
I've heard you even sound [__] up till
about 10 or 11 I could tell like we do
like 8 900 milligram oh Fu because you
have to sweat it out the next day it's
like it's like eating valum in the old
days somebody go oh eat a 10 milligram
valum you eat a Valium the next day and
a half you're sluggish yeah because it's
time release so it sits in your fat like
a lot of times I'll eat a valum at night
and I'll go to bed at 3:00 I'll wake up
at 8: on the road go eat breakfast go
eat the hotel breakfast smoke a joint go
on a computer and pass out at 10 yeah
and I'm still off the fumes you still
got some some resonating stuff don't you
kick that [__] coffee in there
with a a little
it lifts that [__] it lifts up that
[__] reefer right back to where it is
I was high in the plane like two days
ago cuz I had an edible the night before
to help me go to sleep and just chill
and on the flight I was messed up man I
was just this lady I travel with my dogs
right and I sat down at the bar in the
hotel I was coming from um where the
[__] was I North Carolina so you at the
helium in North Carolina no no I was at
the um it was at Comedy Zone North
Carolina Comedy Zone great Club Great
Club great they want you but they've
been asking for you yeah um and I was
sitting at the airport bar and this lady
made me sit at the at the disabled
chairs cuz I had my dog with me I was
like it's an emot emotional support pet
she's you got to sit in the handicap
chairs she made me sit in the handicap
chairs and I was high off these Edibles
like yo am I handicapped right now she
made you change your seat she made me
change my and it was 4 feet lower than
the bar stools so I literally got sat at
the [__] kids table at the bar and
ordered a big ass beer and some oysters
like a goddamn lady sitting at the
disabled person's chair just cuz you had
a dog just cuz I had a dog what my
disabled persons have a dog yeah they're
[__] up at airports now they're
getting weird I I tell you Chicago
scared the [__] out of me the other day
guys why really I'm no swamy but
something's going to happen in Chicago
why do you think that I'll tell you why
because for some reason they've been
showing those TSA lines how they've been
letting people spend the night okay
that's number one I don't want like that
they're letting people spend the night
like they were 2our lines so they're
telling people now if you're flying
through Chicago and big airports 3 hours
I might as well not fly I could walk
there the three and the four flight in
the [__] hour to land and get my
luggage and get the taxi hours it's 10
[__] hours if I start walking I might
beat it so you Dad flew into Chicago to
connect into Pittsburgh and I noticed
something I haven't I fly a lot through
Kennedy yeah and I fly a lot through
Chicago and I can make this assessment
Chicago was [__] packed which one
O'Hara Midway Ohara was packed and it's
never good it needs to be good when it's
packed but it never is I don't like it I
didn't like it back to the amount that
every food place I mean I had to walk
like you know when you go to Chicago you
better be in shape that airport is
[__] something oh [__] it was it's
like an artery so I landed at 11: and my
flight was boarding at
11:35 and as I was walked in I got there
like 5 minutes earlier off the plane I
walked 30 minutes straight I didn't stop
to eat I didn't stop to pee I walked 30
minutes [__] straight to the to where
you had to go to where I had to go as I
was getting there going we're boarding
in 3 minutes I cut right through the
[__] line and got in the plane but I
noticed how pack the airport and were
there a lot of uh cancellations or this
is just [__]
ohar brother this is ohar Thursday it's
12:00 but this was more than chaotic
there was a line at the Italian
restaurant I've been going to Chicago
Hara for 12 years I saw a [__] line
at McDonald's now you go Joey yeah no no
no no this wasn't a line This people
that couldn't get food anywhere else yes
this was the Starbucks was down the
block it was super packed guys was it
like Burger King at LAX you know that
Burger King with like Jeet blue and
virgin it's always like way down it was
that bad it was bad it was bad bad bad
bad that's not good in the TSA you know
like last year 95% of [__] got through
95 percent of them testing the TSA
security got through last week I had a
bag of weed in my [__]
carryon what was happening was I had two
or three different weeds and I'm rolling
joints over here and one of the baggies
fell off into my [__] carry-on bag I
put my computer over it I walked through
the [__] thing no better yet they
took my sleep apne machine out checked
it for [__] illegal fuels but they
left the weed in there the vapor pen the
lighter yes they did cuz they tell you
no lighters no vapor pens they went
through you can't bring a lighter on no
and the vapor pens they look like
regular pens so they're so stupid they
just take the pens out and look at them
and don't even ask you I think all they
look for is water bottles cuz like every
time I get something like that I'll get
stopped like toothpaste or if I get like
that I'll get stop but yeah not you you
travel every week with stuff I check my
Lage right I don't check I don't want to
bring my look at the worst habit we got
is bringing [__] on a [__] plane
because at the end of the week they're
going to make you check it out the
[__] thing anyway yeah yeah they make
you check it anyway they going to make
you check it anyway so stop stop but
they Che fre yeah they but see it's
smarter because you check it at the gate
and it's free a that's right but then
you got to wait for your luggage to get
there when you come back but who gives a
[__] you're sitting in coach by the time
you you get in there your [__]
luggage is ready so at least if you
check it but these people that bring
their luggage in for what for what I
know for what to take up [__] space
yeah what what do you mean unless you're
going to see I'm dog I always get
upgraded to First Class last especially
after the last 3 years of Justin so I I
Bard the plane first yeah me too brother
I don't give a [__] what's going on bye
lady with the kids I don't give a [__]
what's going on I board that plane first
comfort and I always sit in One D you
walk in that seat that you see that's
where I see that little compartment
that's mine don't touch it you don't
need to touch it you don't need to put
your lugage in there listen to me yeah
that's a $3,000 sleep apne machine in
there you touch that [__]
Embrace I will break your [__] head
don't even touch that [__] thing and
they look at well yeah I don't give a
[__] what it is you say that to people
yeah I tell them all time there's no
reason for you to touch that luggage
that's a little luggage for a little
compartment yeah and they look at me all
weird you know what I did my homework
and I got on the plane
first yeah so now I don't get like some
lady came on yesterday I got no
compartment she looked at me I'm like
deaf I don't know nothing I just kept
looking straight ahead you ain't putting
your [__] in there I put a [__]
blanket over it so it looked like there
was more [__] in there yeah that [__]
had to put her [__] in the back [__] it
this is what happens you want to be
firstam it in there get the [__] to the
plane first I checked that boarding time
that boarding time is my [__] Bible
yeah and everything around that boarding
time is is is [__] it last week I
went to LAX my plane leaves at 5 my
boarding time is at 4:30 Lee how much do
I love the hamburgers with the egg and
the [__] fries you're a big fan of
them the guy told me to put the order in
at 420 he'd be at 4:30 I sacrificed I
didn't eat that [__] burger with egg
on it because I wanted my seat first so
there's
no understandings I love traveling with
you cuz like I don't I don't get
upgraded cuz I don't go I don't travel
that often but like he just takes me
into the lines he's like just what are
they going to say you have it's the
attitude you have have that attitude
yeah the attitude and then he just he
starts sweet talking the U like the TSA
the pre- ones like the ones who were
checking your ID before he just oh it's
it's I tormented you do what do you do
what's happened you're looking good
today what's going on you just [__]
you do a little charm yeah [__] yeah you
got to talk to them cuz everybody treats
them like strangers yeah so you talk to
them a little bit and they loosen up and
talk to you listen not everybody's going
to talk to you not everybody's going to
appreciate your sense of humor but at
that time in the morning you got to give
it a shot I tell you know who likes [__]
black black chicks the other chicks like
the compliments right I work them all
the time I call them Beyonce you bad
[__] you look at you I should
take you with me to La La I never been
to La yeah come on let's go and
meanwhile you got [__] 10 bombs and a
kid in
2case and you do it so you can get in
the in the preferred line you got some
kid yelling and screaming in your
suitcase and they don't hear nothing cuz
you're just talking to them you got some
kid in your carryon yeah who gives a
[__] they're talking to you and [__] you
know when you fly you have to fly as is
you have to assume as you have a million
dollars in your pocket if you see a dog
when I see dog and I have weed I walk up
to the dog you do yeah because even if
the dog barks at me they're not going to
believe it a drug offender would walk
away from the dog I walk towards the
[__] dog yeah last night I smoked 15
Joints off as
a meanwhile you got 10 joints in your
[__] carryon bag you know what I'm
saying I always have a joint in my check
luggage I usually do right in the top
with a [__] lighter so when I get to
parking while the car's warming up I'm
the joint Chinese people pull up are you
leaving not really Chinese people always
pull up with [__] lax are you leaving
do I look like I'm [__] leaving I'm
here smoking in the sun like Azie Osborn
in 69 and you want to know if I'm
[__] leaving do I look like I'm
[__] leaving has anyone ever stolen
it like any TSA people never put in the
top compartment with Band-Aids there's a
bunch of [__] in there and I flip the
joint underneath you got to tuck it in I
tuck it in Tuck that [__] in you
can't find it unless you [__] watch
the Takes a Thief 1969 with Robert
Wagner you can't find it you can't find
it you got to have that smooth placement
and then I have the lighter and the
thing so if they find the lighter I say
just told me not to fly with lighters so
when I get out the thing the first thing
I do when I'm on the elevator going up
the stairs to Route floor number three
is I unzip it boom and there's my little
pin joint I take the lighter out I when
I get off the airplane when I get off
the [__] elevator clink clink I click
the alarm in the car I walk to it I
start the car I put my luggage in and
right while I'm out there 9 out of 10 I
take my dick out and I pee I leave the
door open I may believe I'm help putting
my luggage in help get in here but
meanwhile the whole time I'm peeing on
the guy's car next to me I close the
door I light that [__] Tut
and Chinese people start pulling up are
you leaving do I look like I'm leaving
Chinese people Chinese people always
look and they'll wait too I can make
them wait for an hour p like a sedo and
wait pull over there and I'm going to
leave here in about 18 minutes and
they'll wait like the entire time you
smoke The Joint my parking is classic
see cuz I park at 4 in the morning on
Thursday so get front I'm 10 ft from the
[__] elevator like a doctor you leave
your car there the whole time you're on
the road yeah right there right there
terminal the for does does it matter
yeah it doesn't matter does it matter
it's not doesn't matter it doesn't
matter at the end of the week the tax is
$80 [__] doll you're right so 80 and
80 is 160 the parking is 109 oh my God
right in the [__] terminal cross not
the [__] one with the bus with the
spots on it and I got to wait with a
bunch of immigrants and get on the thing
the guy's got a turban I don't know if
he's going to blow up the [__] bus
one I wait for yeah this [__] G much
and then you got to go all the way to sa
yeah and they they wash do you want to
wash the car listen I my car with pigeon
[__] okay give me the [__] car I just
want to get home going to play for 8
hours my hemoid blew up and you want to
know if I want to wash my car I park
right in four terminal four is American
terminal 6 is Delta Terminal 3 is Virgin
American the terminal one is Southwest
yeah that's it that's all you need to
know that's all you need to know I do
Delta Delta if you fly out if you land
at that airport after 6 you're going to
be driving around like a [__] idiot
looking for parking so if your flight's
at [__] 5 you you got to be there at
4:00 I'm lurking at 20 to 4: no one's
there nobody's there you're going to
change the way I travel you pull right
in does that sound happen no and listen
to me you piss again and you cross the
street under that tunnel there's nobody
there you could run across the street
with the light green I'm going to do
that nobody there you get on the
escalator it takes you right to [__]
no [__] boom you go in first class
boom you take it you turn around there's
a black lady who looks like Barry White
that's me you go up the Hub you go
What's happen you sexy mother [__]
what's up darling boom right upstairs
pre TSA they know I'm a [__] fiend
they know I'm a felon when I fly out
other airports I don't get pre-tsa but
LAX pre-tsa don't open up till 20 don't
open up till 20 after 4
though [__] [__] but if you have
a 500 a.m. flight you got 10 minutes but
you still get in the L line and you
still get to your terminal by 4:15 and
now they got a place over LAX it's not
open for [__] the burgers are not
open that's the only place from the
burger place is it 5:00 a.m. oh my god
with the
egg the burger with the egg and steak I
think I know what you're talking
about it's all off the terminal number
42 43 46 that's the only place but when
you fly the Southwest in LAX Terminal
oh they got the Mexican giant with the
bar The margaritas the whole [__]
thing you a margarita no but I sit next
to the person drinking a Margaritas I
look important I'm not an [__]
Delta's got a spot where I always see ma
Jabron and that's the place that you go
through and they got oatmeal and they
got they got the whole thing they got
the juices the watermelon apple
watermelon lemonade water that's a good
one that's a good one cuz like the uh
healthy locks Bagels yeah I love locks
and bagels yeah healthy healthy and you
drop the small 20 but you don't have to
eat that [__] on the plane you don't
have to touch a peanut oh God the plane
food man nothing you drop the small 20
like a gentleman and you don't have to
do nothing after that you get the bowl
oatmeal oatmeal always holds you longer
than anything else and you get a lock
Bagel right there with a watermelon
juice bam who's better than you Lisa
have you ever have you guys ever gotten
caught with the weed or no never don't
jinx us right what the [__]
allegedly allegedly what would you do if
what if you got caught with a weed I
shut my mouth and let them [__] say
whatever they had to say and I move on
with my
life they' bust my balls and the medical
marijuana license I tell them I'm
hearing
voices you know you got to learn how to
work the airport like when I went with
Ari one time when you fly to Kennedy
Kennedy's got a stupid thing Kennedy
will go what time's your flight Miss
paluso 6:00 a.m. we're not letting you
through but the airport said an hour
before yeah but we're not letting you
through there's people that are flying
out of the court of the six that are
more important than you so they'll leave
you behind the
thing that's when I walk up to the lady
they go listen I got high blood pressure
I got HIV you just start DR HIV and high
blood pressure everything just start
dropping disease anal warts I got anal
warts I got a foot rickets I got rickets
scurvy scurvy lupus lupus just drop
dropping and what happens and go I'll
pass out right here in the line they
will [__] treat
you like you a gold because that's the
last thing they want is emergency
especially black people they're lazy
they don't want to [__] dial
911 soal I don't care if you see a
Chinese a white dude you see a black
[__] black people don't give
other people mouth to mouth you'll never
see a picture of a black person giving
mouth to mouth they don't believe in it
I don't believe in it either if you're
choking [__] I don't know who you are I
don't know what how many dicks you suck
last night I'm going to be able to save
your life then I get herpes for saving a
life you know what I'm saying [__] you
you're not worth the herpes next thing
you know I'm getting the metal with a
saw on my lip you know what I'm saying
and the May won't shake my
hand yeah so [__] that noise I'm not I'm
not black people will not give nobody m
the m I've seen it I've seen people
dying for the black people they just sit
there go my Lord that's it that's all
they do they don't give a [__] about
mouth to mouth take a survey amongst
black people behind closed doors with no
face and see what they say [__] that
noise I ain't sticking my tongue in some
motherfucker's mouth to save his damn
life especially if he had just eaten
some like busted sandwich before and the
Crum Crumbs are all in his mouth now
we're going to I choked in in Vegas with
Lis at I got high and ate a whole prawn
from the [__] shrimp barx a whole
prawn oh like a you choked on a prawn oh
my God it got stuck right pipe I started
getting anxiety I was seeing Stars I
don't know how it came out yet did you
cough it up yeah I had to do the humlick
you did yeah yeah you knew how to do the
heck you came back who don't know how to
do the heck you got to be [__] like
I'd break a rib give me some credit at
least my little ass noodle arms I'd
crack a rib on accident well who gives a
[__] at least you save a life you saved
his life yes how have you repa him
that's by loving them all these Edibles
you're in love with all you he repays
you mushrooms and [__] [__] he gets high
every night I think what if you put the
prawn there on purpose so that you could
be the hero I think he did I'm Jewish I
put a prawn there that's actually
interesting that you brought it up cuz I
was thinking today like someone was
complaining about their boring job and I
was I was thinking about I was like I
haven't been bored at
work in what 3 years now four years
however long I've been doing this
fulltime you've never been bored [__] no
why would I why would I be bor bored
here no and it's like it's crazy how
like it it K almost it's almost like
depression when you're bored like for 8
nine 10 hours a day like I was it like
it got me so [__]
depressed I was like you I mean you guys
get to go you were
but there's there's always shitty Parts
about every job but I don't think you're
ever I don't think Joy's ever bored on
stage I'm not really I never get bored
well here's the problem they're stressed
again if we let look if the IRS comes to
you tomorrow and says you owe me
$200,000 then you call your agent you go
you know what I'm on the road every
[__] week yeah and two things are
going to happen you're going to improve
but you're going to get sick you know
you'll irritable you'll get irritable
when once you pay the IRS you'll never
work comedy again you'll be so burnt out
yep I like to work and I'll tell you you
have no idea how fortunate we are to do
what we do if you really break it down
if you really if you get up at 6:00 in
the morning and just go to a 7-Eleven
and just sit there get coffee and sit in
your car and smoke a joint you'll see
how lucky we are yep that we doing what
we doing okay whether it's your dream or
not because there's people that really
are busting their ass for no money for
[__] [__] money and it breaks your
heart but you made a decision and you
suffered also I I lived in a car you
know I had warrants I couldn't pick up
the phone cuz I Ed everybody I go to
comedy clubs and they go somebody coffee
I knew it was a collector because they
looking web pages now you know they'll
look at a web page now I had a friend
that was wanted by the IRS by the time
he got to every Club his money they
already told him you have a they wanted
me to tell them what I was paying you
and they already took the money out oh
my God that's that's just they don't
[__] around in commedy it does not [__]
around there's no insurance people on
the road there's really nothing so the
tide flips are one day you're you have
the ability you know you're not going to
have it for long in comedy you don't
have that big window for long that's why
you have to do all the opportunity for
some people it could be seven years for
some people could be 3 years it depends
on the depth of your comedy and how good
you are as a comedian how you're able to
adapt and there's just so many [__]
variables but I know this when I I did a
eight weer last year Jesus that by the
end you're a different person you're a
different you want to you you look at
standup in a different way and I always
tell this to people that I wish I never
made a dollar doing this like if I had
another chance to do this the best
advice is somebody could have came up to
me and said listen do me a favor don't
think about that [__] keep coming down
here every week do your 10 spots we'll
MC you and if you definitely don't want
to leave and none of that [__] this
becomes more fun for you y you know
there was I had fun in 1982 and 1981
1980 eating drugs and giggling and
robbing people with my friends in northb
and then I left in 83 and I I didn't
have fun again for a long time and
there's times now when I'm like look how
bored of a life I live but if I really
look at my life I look at that time I
spent in Seattle and Denver you know
Denver not as much because
uh I got thrown out of Denver that
comedy scene why because I had
a Denver at the time was very limited
and the comics worked a certain amount
of work anybody who worked out of that
Loop they really didn't like wow like a
certain room or what do you mean so in
those days you work triple runs you work
the guy out of out of uh Dallas his one
nighters you worked Kansas City
stanfords and you worked the four clubs
in Denver you
worked there was rooms you worked if you
worked like the funny B Idaho or San
Francisco you were considered weird they
had their own little circle and then at
the Comedy Works I got accused of sexual
harassment from some girl that jumped on
me and I went to grab her and the
manager saw me grab her ass which when
she jumped on me I grabbed her ass
because she landed I mean if you go to
the Comedy Works it's not of slly it's
little stairs so she ran down and goes
ah look who it is and she jumped I knew
the girl I knew the girl real well but
the manager contacted her the next day
the manager and me were at the same
point in comedy we were getting star
spots the manager was doing stand up
yeah like the assistant manager and he
called her the next day and said I think
you should press charges she contacted
an attorney but there was no charges to
press nothing I mean the girl was my
friend she even called me afterward and
apologize she felt bad but she goes the
guy made her do it and at that time you
know what I was looking to leave so it
was an excuse so it was perfect but my
time in Seattle that 18 months even
though I got arrested five times it's
good ratio oh my God even though I got
arrested five times and I spent maybe
six weeks seven weeks in jail in the
county King County Jail it was one of
the
most some my [__] nie BL you're
blazing up it was one of the
uh compared to how I grew up and where I
grew up this was one of the most
enjoyable times in my life even though I
lived in an office I took showers at the
gym they had a at the end of the office
they had a window like that a bathroom
like this yeah no no they didn't even
have a bathroom they had a one that
washes your hands but they would lock it
at night so at night I have to pee out
my window and [__] out my window if I
wanted to [__] out STI sh the window
stick my ass out the window like this
and put the window on my back so I
wouldn't fall backwards [__]
tremendous you can't [__] out of a
window [__] out of the window in an
office in an office and wipe my ass and
throw the toilet paper off the window
and the bucket and then take it to the
bathroom and unbeli sounds very like you
you're acrobatic this is this
was it was amazing just did anyone come
up to your office and be like someone's
[__] outside no where go nothing who
knows how far up were you who knows two
floors and the you do you ever go down
and see like [__] streaks in the window
I looked through the window one time and
there was like you could see where all
the [__] land was
dehydrating there was like skeletons or
[__] and like it was like skeleton [__]
skeletons a [__] yard but they can't all
be they're not all Sol if if I wipe my
ass it was a big chunk of [__] I'd throw
it out the the window if it was just a
little bit of [__] I throw in the waste
paper basket just a horrible way to live
but you ever Shard out the window and
like just spray up the building no no no
it was all shits there and peas I puke
from doing coke in that office I had a
table
with a blanket on the floor and I slept
on the blanket on the floor and under
the table was my luggage that was it
that was it I had a 1 1800 number so
people could call me I ran a sports
betting and I had a regular phone that I
could call out with long distance that's
it there was no pictures on the wall and
you doing comedy then and I was doing
comedy two blocks away at the
underground and downstairs Josh Wolf ran
the bar josa I love Lobo Loco Brody
Stevens was living up there with his
mother
oh my God yeah so it was a fun pack but
one of my highlight memories was doing
the Mariner the the Seattle comedy
competition and Sunday getting free
tickets to a a Seattle Seahawk game I
forget again two but here's 15 Comics
that have been competing against each
other now we're all sitting together
smoking pond eating hot dogs talking
[__] and I remember sitting there making
a note that no matter what happens with
comedy at least I got this from at one
time in my life you know it was so much
fun that calar it's important to
remember those little ass moments man
all that [__] so fleeting you know it's
it's especially now it's like
everything's so fast everything goes so
fast because news is constantly being
shoved in our face with social media and
all this updating and post and it feels
like moments are going by faster than
they did before doesn't it well when you
get older I mean listen it was Christmas
yeah two weeks ago right it was [__]
it goes by so [__] fast and
especially you have a kid everything's
in like these little digestible moments
it's important to hang on to those like
times when you feel that it's the best
well between you and I have held on to
Good Times where in my mind there have
been many like I my
mind but I also held on to bad times so
I knew how good the good times tasted
you know what I'm saying perspective the
good times tasted [__] good you
sometimes you work at club or something
when they put you in this big hotel room
yeah and you lay on the bed and Lee
comes up and says look at this place and
when Lee leaves I go you know yeah look
at this place but I wish leas would have
seen the place I lived in the office
yeah more Lee would have seen when I
lived in Boulder and start it cly or
when I [__] lived in a car around
Sunset and I'd have to move it because
of not at 4:00 a.m. they tow it so I
always had to park on those side streets
on Sunset Boulevard you think of those
times and even in that [__] car I
used to have great times I would jerk
off in that car right on Sunset right on
the side of Vista there good for you i'
do Coke jerk off in the car people would
pass by I'd make believe I was sleeping
and [__] I'd have the car running with
the air on and the sunroof open so I go
look at the stars you know what I'm
saying how [__] crazy so when you
have those good times you think of those
times in the car you need that [__] I
think of a time in Idaho when I was
coming home from a midnight trible run
and I [__] was drinking Mountain Dews
oh God and inhaling [__] no zone no
no no that [__] almost gave me a heart
attack that Stu is no joke I got pulled
over in in New Mexico I was doing 90 in
a station wagon from no do no do and uh
what's the what's the NS like the
grapefruit energy drink whatever that is
oh my God the cop asked if I had
military training and I was chubbier
than I was now and [__] of mini of
[__] the station W I like no why do
you asking for a military training cuz I
was shaking on this
because no will make your heart explode
that shit's terrible cuz the idiot that
I was I wouldn't get like a nice light
breakfast to drive across the country I
got like [__] McMuffins or something
so 20 minutes into the drive I was
falling asleep so I'd always stop and
get like the no do and the the Nos and
I'm I was apparently just going like
people usually calm down after a certain
point you're still
shaking I have to ask do you have any
military background I was like no but
you were shaking because of the caffeine
and you were scar
you're a sweethart of a guy scared and I
was petrified I thought I thought about
running cuz I was I had planned that you
could have gotten far on that I think I
could have cuz I planned at the next
exit I was going to stop to get for
lunch and I saw him he was right in the
middle like in like the middle of
nowhere the highways don't even have
like rails they just have like a ditch
so he's in the ditch and I as soon as I
passed him I was like [__] but he had to
turn around and there's an exit right
there I was like maybe I'll take the
exit but I was just like I don't want to
go to jail for trying to run into me you
could you know I I did I got pulled over
once I was going I was like 75 and a 50
and the dude pulled me over and before
he could ask for my he he was like
licens to registration I was like I'm
going to get it for you but I just want
you to know I just got my period and it
bled through the seat and my dad's going
to kill me cuz it was like tan seats I
was like my dad's going to kill me
Sicilian he lik to keep the car nice and
mint you know I'm going to get yelled at
when I get home so I was just pulling
off to get a tampon that's why I was
going so fast and he just looked at me
so disgusted he was like just go just
get out of my face hilarious he was so
gross yeah cuz he doesn't want to [__]
now either he was like what a [__]
perver you know what let me smell the
seats let me smell the seats you filthy
[__] animal let me smell that hog
smell that
Band-Aid now where did you start comedy
or you got into the girl code first
break it down for me I where you from
originally Syracuse New York by the mall
yeah by the mall have you done the
funnyone
I used to
do Wise Guys back in the day with Bruno
Sheri [__] Bruno who would do your jokes
the week later this guy was a was a p I
tell you piece of work and Joe yeah the
lion yes so Bruno owned the club and Joe
the liion was the house MC magician yes
and that club was
brutal brutal down town you wake up on
Saturday
nothing to eat nothing nothing Ghost
Town nothing to eat and I had like a
history in
Syracuse you're well known to love
magicians because no I had a what
happened
was what happened was that I went to
Bruno sharib I just got here in LA in 98
and the guy I was with books me Wise
Guys yeah Bruno sharip I go up there
[__] ripped the week apart the
headlin is complaining it's a be room
man I'm at the comedy story night doing
20 it's not even fair yeah the feature
cancels so he asked me he goes you just
want to spend the week I said [__] yeah
so he takes me to his house this one
even still married he feeds me I mean
his wife his kids great Italian family
this delion or Bruno this is Bruno he's
a a black belt in Taekwondo nuts nut so
he's got a [__] karate studio by that
point was 350 lb 325 and he would take
me to do karate he would try to teach me
how to eat right so wait had you been
losing weight no Bruno's like you got to
stop this lifestyle oh it's way before
that he's like you got to stop drinking
fruit juice and sodas he goes I watch
you you drink a gallon of pineapple
juice the other night in my bar Bruno
was a solid dude but then he got in
trouble for robbing money from the
casino Yeah Tuesday nights and then the
club closed and then the line took it
over but when by the time the lion took
it over it was called Viva debris yes
viva debris oh my God I remember that
when I was a kid Viva [__] debris and
he was a magician and he was in reality
Joe delion was one of the best magicians
in the world that's what people don't
realize but here's what gets scarier
guys and you're hearing this from me
sometimes you go and there's a magician
opening up for a good headliner or
something and the magician does corny
jokes and [__] grandpar parents laugh
and whatever yeah in reality Joe de was
a killer
comedian he was such a killer that he
couldn't get M features because to save
money when he first opened the bar he
goes I'm just going to house MC do some
magic tricks he was doing magic at the
bar yeah before the show started and
then he' take you in the back and then
he'd do the magic you know uh and then
he bring up a feature the reputation he
was so strong off the Jump that he
couldn't get features features were
[__] hating life was it the same
material or was it new all the time he
had he was he was a 20-year comedian oh
he had [__] n hours of [__] killer
[__] his parents got sick he went up
there to take care of him he took the MC
hosting job so when the club reopened
Bruno was Gone with his wife but he was
banging this lady who had a a lawn care
service she had a a a la like she yeah
and she was divorced but the husband was
rich he run off with a 20-year-old and
just paid this [__] off just paid that
[__] off like you want 3 million I'll
give you four take the kids what I'm
looking for take the kids I don't want
to see the ugly [__] kids they're
your side of the family anyway they're
half a [__] I swear to God I wish I was
lying to you whatever she wanted he goes
hey I'll give you a million more God I'm
going to [__] Spain to [__] this
little 20y old in the ass La V [__] the
kids so Bruno's banging this chick and I
would go up there and do two weeks at a
time so in those three days instead of
staying at the hotel Bruno would talk
her into me staying at the house and she
was great the lady I got along great
with her she smoked dope yeah she had a
dealer down the corner some little
neighborhood in Syracuse right there
real nice house new and she had a Lomo
and I ended up working for her so those
days I was in Syracuse I would work in
the daytime make a hundred bucks a day
moving rocks and you know me though you
got to put two and two together I got
cabit yeah you got to get up yeah it's
expensive you got to get up child
support so I didn't give a [__] for me
if I went to Rochester Buffalo Syracuse
any of those neighborhoods I lived at
that lady's house I played with the kids
I hung out her and I would smoke dope at
night then her and Bruno broke up oh the
worst deal and I'm in the middle now and
she like to suck dick so he would ask me
has she suck your dick yet and I would
go no but she would wake me up every
morning and I would like some mornings
I'd have like hard on and go all right
this morning I'm going to let her suck
my dick I never had the heart I liked
her too much you know she would get
drunk and we talk dirty to each other
but I never did I never pulled the
trigger on it I just kept working and
then guess what I came back to LA I used
to do those six Monon road trips this is
99 when you went out and do do the road
yeah because there was I I had to follow
Nick depalo one night and Stan was
behind me and I died at the Improv at
one of those 9 15 spots I died I
realized how bad I was so I would do six
Monon chunks on the road 6 months at a
time send clothes home yep hit a Walmart
buy a whole new [__] wardrobe for
3250 that's the way to do it and send
boxes home every week every two weeks
boom those jeans well we were talking
before the show about like coming back
Monday and having to leave Tuesday at a
certain point what's the why even have
an apartment that's the hardest thing
for me have like the past two years have
an apartment I you know it's like so
[__]
painful to pay that
check every month so you got to find a
friend who's got a spare bedroom who'll
give it to you for a deuce or three
bills tell that he could but see but
then you don't want it you know cuz
you're with people all weekend but then
you get there and he rented it to
somebody else now your panties are
getting worn by a man I don't mind that
part no the [__] the pillow smells
like ass that already happen so you have
to you have to choose the life you want
it's nice to have your own space you
know uh people always say are you on
tour I don't know what the [__] a tour
is I'm on the road this week I don't
know nothing about no [__] tour yeah
but my life is tour like right now I
would love to do a thre Monon and just
get it over with for the whole year yeah
but I miss I'd miss my wife and like I
missed a that's too much that's too much
that's not the way to raise a child if I
was 28 36 I could do it and snort blow
and eat fried food at the bar I did it
for years it's too much though man I'd
like to come home home for me it's like
you got to find that balance when you're
on the road you got you have to have a
home man don't you think for your own
sanity just to a place where you can go
and think the thoughts you need to say
on stage well when you first get into
comedy you want to get immers in it so
you want to live with four guys yeah you
want to do all that [__] that do
comedy they're all hustling they get you
a job you all work at the same
restaurant that's part of the experience
that's part of your book when you hit a
bait yeah but then it comes a time when
you move on and you now you live with
your boyfriend now that's different he
doesn't do comedy right so you're out at
night and he works days that's a
different part of the relationship that
there's so many [__] levels of Comedy
yeah and if you want to be good it's the
same thing if you want to be good a good
Carpenter I come on board with your dad
I think your dad's a construction dude
in Syracuse I come on board with your
dad after the first year I'm getting
good at it and I'll go [__] it I'll work
weekends I'll run a crew on a weekend
and learn this and you do that for four
years you become a really good Carpenter
or a mason or a [__] Chef if somebody
says to you hey I have weekend work for
you and you really love cooking and you
really want to learn the trade it's not
weekend work no it's not it's just
another [__] day at the zoo so yeah
your first eight nine years of Comedy
your love and so and your passion should
be so much it's just and that's what it
was for me it was that way for
me for about 12 and a half years once it
got the LA it got real yeah
that's a little too real that's how I
that's how I felt when I got here a
little too quick it's different and that
knocks to wig off a lot of people it's
very understandable a lot of people come
to La do a couple sets and go this ain't
for me yeah is I love it is it the clubs
is it the the town itself or
everything's different from La comedy is
different from Comedy anywhere else in
the country it's a totally different uh
your approach to it has to be completely
different there's no laziness there's no
room for laziness don't you think so I I
know so I know many of people I could
count 10
I'm thinking about him right now I know
guys that came rented apartments and
took off after two
weeks made up some story never came back
my uncle my dad none of them really said
to you I don't really like it or I
really can't handle
it I can name 10 people I can name four
people who lasted less than a month that
I know of since
1997 and I can name 50 people who have
left since yeah and people who had
Talent I'm not talking about people who
came out that weren't even at that point
I'm talking about people who you saw at
the store people who you saw at
auditions people who you saw at
different comedy clubs and one day
you're working [__] St Louis and they
contact you on
Facebook and because your life is filled
with faces you forget and you go bro
where the [__] oh my God and they'll
tell you what happened you call him up
what happened what are you doing here oh
I got stuck here you know La man man and
the girl broke up and I had no apartment
and you hear it in their voice that that
it broke them because you have to
maintain a high level of [__] in
your life I'm not even a comedian and
just driving down in Burbank the other
day and there's Billboards everywhere
and you're driving past Disney and it's
every conversation you have is about it
and every conversation you hear even if
you just go to be quiet every
conversation you hear is about this
meeting or whatever I it's it's kind of
cliche to say it but there there's a
different feeling in in La even for me
so I can't imagine having to perform it
feels
like you can go out and when I the way I
approach it is I go out in my mind I'm
like anything can happen tonight in LA
and I felt that way when I was in New
York I was in New York for almost 9
years you know I always wanted to
perform in a way that I would be tired
when I got off stage or sweating or my
heart was still racing
because the Jesse May 11 years ago or 12
years ago whenever I started would have
done that so why would I change that
approach I I don't think it's you know
when I see comedians being lazy and
taking you know shortcuts it really irks
me because like you said we're very
fortunate to be able to do this to be
able to make a living at it [__]
forget about it how many people make a
living doing stand up very [__] few
and how many people are out there trying
to do it a shitload so to me laziness
there's no room for it last Thursday was
my true test last Thursday was the
fourth week in a row no I did four out
of
five and last Thursday I had to get up
at 2:30 to be at the airport by
4: flight was leaving at 5: there was a
lunchtime flight that I looked at the
day before I did get so [__]
fanatical about it I looked at the
lunchtime flight the day before and I
said I'll get there at 7:30 I'll make
the show I would never do something like
that to a club owner on myself that's a
horrible stress to put yourself
under I still remember that alarm going
off at 2:30 in the morning last W
Thursday and my wife didn't sleep with
me cuz she don't want me to wake her up
in the middle night so she blows up a
[__] hand mattress and sleep in the
baby's room with the
baby I remember opening the door and
they were one inch from each other their
faces and they were looking at each
other and they fell asleep like playing
like looking at each other do you have
any idea how hard it is to leave that
like not to say are you [__] kidding
me I'm going to do what and then I got
on the 101 and there was bumper to
bumper traffic one lane I shot off that
[__] at cold water and I did 90
all the way to [__] suppo with a 405
I shot down I made it to the airport at
10 the [__] 4: I walked into the
airport I couldn't believe 10 the
[__]
four but it's so hard to leave that like
right there I'm was like I'm going to
what Pittsburgh I'm leaving this to go
to Pittsburgh I made my wife sleep on
the floor to go to Pittsburgh at this
level at this level that my wife just
said well I can sleep on the c ah she
blew up the mattress my wife didn't mind
but I still remember being a criminal
fulltime I did a six-year [__] run of
just P the steel from Paul yeah and if
you don't have it by Friday somebody's
getting robbed yeah someone's going to
finger marry somebody's going to [__]
get robbed I'll never forget going to
Colorado and leaving and the first six
weeks I was in Colorado I pretty much
slept because all those years my stress
level was at such a high
peak it was at such a high peak you know
last night I I had jet lag so I got off
the plane yesterday at 8:30 in the
morning
I went home I played with the family I
hung out I ate lunch with them I think I
went down at 2: I got up at 5:30 I ate
dinner with him we talked Sunday we said
prayer whatever the
[__] at 10:00 I went to bed last night I
was tired but I had so jet lag or
whatever the [__] you call it yeah I
woke up at 3:00 in the morning angry as
a
[__] woke up like my mind had
just put all the [__] I've been pissed
about for the last 3 weeks in the tip of
my mind like got up I drank half a
gallon of apple juice it was the baby's
Apple Juice I was so
dehydrated that I popped [__] half a
gallon of water I did three more CBD
drops under my tongue and I couldn't go
back to sleep I was W I woke up at 3:00
got up my wife came out like 20 minutes
later you okay and we started talking
she goes why are you mad I go I woke I'm
[__] mad can you believe this [__]
she goes what do you mad about so we
started talking about what I was mad
about she goes if I want to go to the
zoo tomorrow I'm going to have to go
back to bed I all right she went back
back to beened like maybe 10: to 4:00 I
stayed there till 5:30 watching the sons
of anak and what's an episode of Sons of
anak I watched the episode of Sopranos I
watched The Honeymooners I had tape the
night before I didn't get to watch that
I watched the honeymoon uh what one one
season what's that honeymoon was how
long wasn't it on for like one season
they had a 20 something episodes yeah
that's it but they got like really good
episodes that come out Sundays at 10:30
so I tape them that's good one night a
week that we get the [__] one night a
week for you East Coast [__] suckers
one night Sunday at 10:00 I get The Odd
Couple at 10:30 I get the
honeymoons and I watch them every Monday
morning myself that bring you such
[__] yeah it destroys my
insights last night was the one about
the
boxer have you ever seen that one when
he shooting pool no and the guy comes
over the guy's got a squeaky
voice and the guy's got a squeaky voice
the writing
listen there's two guys who were r on
that show and Jackie Gleason Jackie
Gleason
oversaw and let me tell you I read the
book Jackie gleon described them as two
Jews without a sentent cuz all they did
was write brilliant [__] yeah and in
this particular episode he's shooting
pool with Norton he walks in the pool
table's open he gets on the pool table
within four minutes guy comes up to him
with a squeaky voice and says I wouldn't
do that if I was you and he goes why he
goes you know this is me and my friend
Harvey and they start making fun of the
guys of name so yo what your your
friend's Harvey Harvey all a sudden he
goes yeah and my friend Harvey's even
bigger than me and Ru goes I got a
friend Shirley that's even bigger than
you so all a sudden Harvey comes back
he's a professional boxer he Taps Ralph
and he and all of a sudden [__]
Norton is
hysterical I mean if you're looking to
do comedy
timing and I don't even know know what
his name is anymore his real name Ed
Norton in the [__] thing he kept
peeking over his shoulder going hey
Ralph I think he's even bigger than your
friend Shirley like he he was just
throwing Ralph
cronal Carney was a comedy the timing
and I'm watching this this morning and
my wife is arguing with the baby in the
[__]
kitchen and about the part where he uh
Norton comes down and talks him into it
he goes you you got to fight him
everybody's down there everybody's
betting on you you're 500 to one you're
going to lose and he's just tormenting
them he goes you can't leave town he
goes let me teach you how to box let's
work on your
footwork and he's working on his
footwork and all a sudden he goes all
right cover your face cover your face
Ralph covers his face and he [__]
punches him in the stomach right and
right when he punched him in the stomach
I broke down into tears we did yeah
broke down into tears and I'll tell you
all the components of this a a
you going to write it down I grew up
watching
it when my mother was alive right and as
I was watching it I'd be on the
phone with either Fernie next door uh
Fernie his name was uh I forget now the
kid who [__] the Lysol cam blew up
and went through his leg and
[__] the guy with the bikes the guy with
the bikes I hit him on Facebook and
never returned
me I'd be on the phone with him laugh
Laughing Now number two I've seen all
these
episodes 100 times a piece yeah why am I
still [__]
laughing and number three it's who I am
today yeah that comedy is who I am today
I wanted to be Ralph grandon there's no
even my wife looks at me throughout the
thing because that's the first person I
saw that really took it yeah Richard Pry
was a great standup but the do it in
front of me then I saw Red Fox on S and
you see all these other influencers
crossover but [__] that show every
every Monday first thing I do on Monday
when I wake up no
news no nothing I get my coffee and I
chill you got to have that chill moment
and it brings me back and it's three
levels it's three levels of uh what
happened to [__] uh do you know they
took every song off you're correct every
every [__] song we brought it back so
big that MCA record said it's over yeah
where is it oh okay it's time for Tony
benett it's Monday little something for
the spirits you know what I'm saying
something for the spirits [__]
you sorry about squeezing the water
bottle and people get offended why they
want to be
[Music]
around pick up the it's time to smoke a
number if you got it that's what it's
time for
[__] a smoke break eat some
nicotine gum put on your grandmother's
glasses and take a
ride get on the skateboard now
[__] you will go home with a
stitches it's also time for another
mushroom oh [__] I'm full in mushroom
your face looks like a mushroom right
now you're so high go what are you
talking about one more little St one
more little stem come on you're so high
one more little stem for Jesus it's
Monday this is amazing you look amazing
what put what did you put Jesus Through
what did your people put Jes it wasn't
me it wasn't me with the [__] thorn
crown one of your uncles you got to
assume one of your cousins you're all
related where is it don't worry about it
I got more oh I found it leave it there
leave it there the cat will get it get
it no leave it there the cat will get it
the cat the cat on the mushroom oh my
God somebody sent me a video of a dog
that ate Edibles today it was the
saddest thing what happened to it the
owner kept couldn't pick it up the guy
with his eyes were wide open they were
[__] dilated he go Le this is small
did it did it hurt the dog hey go Le
don't let that one go down that's small
yeah these are all baby mushroom I feel
like the other I feel like the other
one's smaller here you go Leah River dir
you there you go I'm going to send it
off on the Snapchat for you okay that's
how we do it couple mushrooms during the
break get the party started Fourth of
July is going to be here before you know
it oh my
God that is impressive that's a little
one yeah he's just lying that's not
little that's a baby one that's huge
noey I get these mushrooms from [__]
Africa that they give to black people
before they put them on the
ship these that thing looks huge n the
ones they got the cap that's the one
he's going to see the devil he ain't
going to see a devil T I gave milligrams
of reefa I don't care that I squeeze the
BN this is who gets offended by bottles
being squeezed people have stopped
listening to the show sometimes you make
a mistake and you squeeze a bottle and
this just refrigerator's on fire got
these ice dicks in them I love a good
ice dick I love I love this [__] my wife
freezes this like the white trash that
she is and I got to tell you in the
middle of night you get up and you drink
that bottle that's delicious oh my
[__] goodness some cold Edibles yeah
little ice dick to go home with little
ice dick to go never get lonely there
used to be a carel in Syracuse I used to
go to oh yeah there's a few Carell still
one there was one particular I used to
go I used to make my milkshake thin
little Chinese guy very thin I like a
thin you know what I'm saying did you
ever know my why do you like get thin
it's so I made a thin shake the other
day about two weeks ago like watery yeah
put vanilla ice cream a lot of whole
milk and a [__] scoop of cane sugar
don't drink that whole milk
B but now I put coconut milk with
Vanilla Ice oh [__] good for you that's
good I make almond milk smoothies every
every morningly and I love it that's
good you put good nuts in there I put
fruits I put mixed berries and cherries
and some flax seeds oh do you put chia
seeds in and hemp seeds flax seeds flax
seeds are good add some Chia in there I
put some uh CD CBD oil on my [__]
tongue for 60 seconds and you become a
[__] weapon you understand me who the
[__] you think you're dealing with joy
bananas what's wrong with milk Joey
bananas yeah what's wrong with milk D
milk is man that stuff is so gross that
comes out of a cow's breast I can't
whole milk I can't [__] with whole milk
it's very funny how I'm sitting here
looking at you and I realized for the
first time how beautiful you are oh
you're so sweet your cheekbones and
stuff but you're also so very
Italian your dad Italian and Mom's
Italian everybody's Italian what's your
mom's maiden name my mom is is a mut so
what's her maiden name Finley Finley
okay she's Irish that's the beauty
[__] yeah that's the prettiness I
I've always been a suck of Irish women
the dirty I like them dirty love them
love them love them since day one dog
those freckles on the tits when you're
in CRA in I got tit freckles I feel left
out oh my god when they're redheaded
there was a redhead sitting next to me
on the flight to Sacramento with Felicia
Felicia's like what are you looking at I
kept looking she couldn't she was
beautiful she looked like the chick from
Boogie Nights First off okay I was going
to say the Wendy's that red hair that
red hair no no that's too red [__] that
I like yeah I like that red and they got
to have pale skin yeah I like skin and I
like the freckles the freckles on the
arm tip freckles the feet were [__]
tremendous she had acne foot fungus I
saw a you want to do to theot why did
you like that because that means she
runs in the woods I could get her out
there running you know what I'm saying I
could chase her with a knife also means
she's probably like vulnerable yeah I
love it she was beautiful when she got
made up on the plane I was watching her
put her eyebrows on she's [__]
beautiful to be a woman we have to put
our eyebrows on do you even know what
the [__] that feels like you you
[__] sitting here with your
with your Burly ass eyebrows and the
world loves you yeah but you got [__]
eyebrows and somebody pays the rent so
complain you know what I'm saying I got
nice eyebrows nobody's paying taking me
to dinner I have niow your eyebrows are
all over the place and you're adorable
oh my eyebrows women have stopped me
stopped me nine out of 10 times and go
can I ask you a question do you have a
sister like cuz the eyebrows got to be
out not the what are these eyebrows no
no they like this I
women go crazy over these eyelashes they
say that they grow weird my eyelashes
grow to what you ladies want them to do
they curl so a lot of women have come up
to me over the years and said your
eyelashes are tremendous out know all
the [__] things have you thought
about doing any modeling any eyelash
yeah yeah I mascara I just sent the
[__] uh packet to Mad Magazine all
right to be an eyelash model whatever
the [__] it is yeah I get mad when dudes
have nice lashes because women have to
extend them or something she was tell we
got to put we have to put put like bore
baby bore fat on our face to feel pretty
and we have to put colors and chemicals
and Shack [__] onto our face you guys
walk around with your Burly ass eyebrows
and your lashes and you're [__] fine
you could smell like salami and have
[__] hair from your temple to your
chin and I don't need salami no more
cuz I did last week last week was the I
don't eat salami anymore but I did last
week my wife bought salami again to put
the [__]
and I found it at night I me a salami
sandwich and I was leaving at 3:30 in
the morning I'm not hungry when I wake
up I'm starving no I don't wake up with
Hunger I have to have that coffee first
then I got to wait 10 minutes then I got
to hit the tutut and then once I hit the
tutut about an hour later when I smell
bacon before I go on the shower and I go
you know what I could eat some at one
point do you [__] out the window uh you
ever do that for Old Time sake no about
8 years ago I started [__] in tubs
cuz I just couldn't take it no more
while shut up while I was taking a
shower why get out let me tell you
something for some reason or another
listen to me J for some reason or
another for about two years every I hate
going I like [__] before I go in the
shower but I like [__] before I go
in the shower I don't want to take a
shower and then walk around with a dirty
ass all day because it leaks you got to
B you got to stop every hour and clean
it and then it gets hot out so I don't
like it I like taking the [__] before I
go in the shower but there's some days
the system don't work according to your
[__] [__] schedule so you wash and
then you come out some days I was taking
a shower and as soon as the water would
hit my back I have to take a [__] and
that's a worst let me tell you something
when you got a dry off to take a sh and
it's and it and it makes you have to go
to the bathroom as soon as the water
hits you so sometimes you do sit on a
wet toilet and it's a horrible feeling
it's a worse feeling it's a horrible
feeling so for a while there I was just
saying [__] it let me just [__] while
I'm taking a shower so you you would
would you scoop it out no I would either
un screw that thing sometimes I pick it
up with my hand just throw it
right Joe stop that's how disgusting I
am sometimes I would just [__] in Vegas
sometimes I was eating pills and doing
blow and I would just sit in the thing
with my legs open like a Chinese guy you
know how they [__] in China but only
with water hitting my ball sack and my
[__] at the same time it's a party
and I would just [__] and watch the [__]
come out with all the particles and then
I get like the soap and push it down the
hole like yes I would I'm disgust I I
got to admit to it right now anybody
who's ever taking a shower at Joey
Diaz's house no not house I would do it
in
hotels Jesus push it down the peanuts
would get stuck in the thing so the
drain couldn't go back down you don't
know I can't see
hotels I'm never staying in another
hotel you don't know what life is like
like now I do this had to be 2006 to
2007 come on you had a [__] year you
know you know the year you were doing
this I was just [__] in the tub
everywhere I was going you know how some
comedians have like
like Josh Wolf has like the picture from
his hotel room he us just take pictures
of the [__] now I don't I don't do that
no more that's when I was an animal this
was way before the baby way before I got
married you don't [__] in the shower my
wife caught me one time in the old
apartment she caught me tossing the [__]
and she goes what was that it was a
midair she just caught it like midair
[__] with the stin flying off and it was
rolling in the air with water on these
did the splash get her and it just
splashes he goes what was that I go I
accent and she you can't be having
accents no more you're too old for that
[__] and that was it cuz once my wife
catches me that's it your wife caught
you tossing [__] the right in the air
like a canoli like a little [__] canoli
just women's softball surf unbelievable
wait would you [__] on the floor and
then pick it up or [__] into your hand
no I would [__] on the floor Let It Drop
boom boom boom I would be washing my
back and then I just bend over important
detail I just bend over like a mule and
let the hot water it was like a Puerto
Rican betet that's what I would use the
shower like a Puerto Rican bed I don't
like those he can't handle his life
right now no and I don't like those
things those shower things that I don't
like that cuz you're never cold if you
take the thing off the thing then you're
freezing so your balls are warm but your
back is freezing so I don't like that I
like water everywhere if you go to these
new modern hotels in Vegas they got a
couple different directions that water
is coming from don't get me wrong I get
tempted you get temped the hotel they
put me in Vegas now they have a chair in
there oh that's a party a chair in the
shower in the shower oh that's so you
can like sit down and sit down yeah take
sh comfortably there times I just go in
there and lay there and think of jokes
and [__] that's my best work when I'm in
a shower yeah I do too I love I love 10
2 Hour 3 hour the old apartment I had in
Hollywood the guy told us the water tank
was from 1910 where it was the size of a
city I would sit in that when I first
had to sleep at me I would sit in the
shower from 3:00 in the morning to 8:00
in the morning when you get pruny the
[__] W the wallpaper the [__]
wallpaper and the paint would come off
the walls and I would just sit there I
get a pillow I put a plastic bag around
I put it behind my head before the sleep
apne machine that's the only way I could
sleep cuz it's a slant and steam you'd
fall asleep in the
shower with the hot water hit in my
chest like a
doctor that's the the way the Greeks did
it in the old days like a doctor [__]
yeah is that documented turn the lights
off [__] it leave me in here with the
hot water hitting my chest cast me what
kind of doctor sleeps in the shower a
doctor a real [__] doctor somebody
was making big time [__] cash what
kind of doctor listen if I ever make big
time cash I'm going to design a house
with a mattress in the shower and a
unlimited tank of hot water I feel like
I was drowning I would not H my chest on
a slant nice steam you breathing nice
you put some elliptic Eucalyptus in the
[__] humidifier whatever who gives a
[__] you're you're literally making a
humans sized humid
like a huge humidifier he just
needs he doesn't need the sleep apne
machine he just [__] waterproof
Rolling Papers smoke some tuts in the
[__] shower who's better than you
Lisa nobody that's amazing shower [__]
you if I could smoke weed in the shower
do you know how many joints I'd smoke
you know how brilliant [__] would come
out of my mouth yeah there's times I go
on the show you can't write I need a
waterproof pen with waterproof
paper you have waterproof paper no I
wish I could get it they got they got to
have
that something that I could write under
water like if it gets wet it doesn't
matter merid snorkel like riding underw
that' be fun though do you eat do you
eat in in the tub you eat a sandwich or
something that's disgusting oh okay
that's disgusting says a guy who just
how you threw a [__] Jello and [__] in
the tub like you [__] some people do
a beer don't they yeah I'll do I'll do a
shower a beer I don't need none of that
[__] I need no shots no glass I can
never be one of those people who drink
wine they go into this deep fog and they
open their eyes you know when you ever
go to a meeting people hug each other
and they close their I never got I
closed my eyes once nothing happened I
never close my eyes again even when you
make out that's the creepiest thing in
the world I got to close my eyes nothing
happens I want to stare at you you know
what I'm saying Mak you keep your eyes
open [__] yeah like a dead person I
don't [__] around when you sleep no no
oh I was like oh my God I got a cat that
sleeps with his eyes open it's the
creepiest thing that's scary she sleeps
with her eyes halfway open you got to go
like check it from time to time Lulu get
it
together that's my friend's dog's name I
love Lulu that's my girl again I took
that from the honeymoons that's from the
episode Norton was sleepwalking so they
hypnotize him they kept saying Lulu Lulu
and they got him a [__]
dog [__] I'm not over you throwing [__]
disgusting we do listen man we do some
disgust I used to love to pee in foam
boots you pee in a foam booth that was
my life like just for a gag take my dick
out and make believe I was talking on
the phone and just pee and watch
thousands of people walk past me while I
had my dick out peeing on the floor it's
amazing what you don't see that's why I
tell people all the time like
people you know they get away they don't
get away with murder and I say read
those mafia
books those mafia books they took you in
the weed they didn't make a big deal of
it and that's why yes the rats told
where the bodies were but there's still
a hundred and those guys are not
geniuses
they're not
Geniuses they'd wrap the [__] trunk
up they'd wrap the top up they'd take
you for a ride shoot you in the head
with a 22 so the Bullet wouldn't
splatter cuz when I shoot you with a 22
there's not a whole W come out of the
other side the 22 just goes around in
your head and crushes your brain that's
why when you want to shoot somebody in
the head you shoot them with a 22 I was
just thinking about that today that
[__] [__] up cuz the chick lived
remember when bought a Fuko shot I don't
know what the gun she shot with when Amy
uh oh yeah um shot the mother in the
head with the gun that's right B wow I
forgot about badafuko when I first got
to La I see B Fuko every night really at
The Comedy Store that must have been
weird Joey B Fuko with his wife at The
Comedy Store [__] and then him by
himself and then auditions I always went
up against
him they always put him in in that my
category an Italian bus dri a pizza guy
I always see B fuk with all the
audition then he did a porno and then
everything ended he's got a body shop in
the valley or he sold it you know he had
a body shop right in Van Ice for years
that's when he moved out he had came out
with a van a body shop he sold
it you got to shoot with a 22 but all
the do you want to know that LE I watch
those CNBC shows and people always
getting caught with murder for stupid
[__] and you're like it's just dumb [__]
how did three guys murder somebody and
nobody knew nothing for 22 [__] years
well they got to stop showing these
shows cuz no one's going to solve murder
murders in like 20 years maybe even less
everyone's going to be taking notes with
all his technology and murders are just
going to be done so easily well see now
with the technology they got you I think
they even have you with the drones of
course they have us with our cell phones
well I I'm not going to take a cell
phone to bury you I'm not that stupid
I'm I'm going to take my car with the
GPS take drone pop pop a cap pop a 22 in
his ass would have drone yeah right
through the butthole there's already a
hole there
that's a [__] that's a thing from a
movie you see there's a new drone that
you can actually sit in now no it's not
out yet but you can sit in a
drone bet you're [__] happy you can't
wait to get your little hat with the
propeller I need I'm a nerd but I I like
to wait till like the second or third
version of stuff like the self-driving
car I really want but you can't go first
I'm
not it's there's going to be a recall
yeah computers break down and stuff so
I'm like a second imagine being the
first one that don't stop and there you
on on the 405 at 5: in the morning doing
90 you're an [__] you're like why did
I even believe this [__] that this is
going to even be possible yeah like I'm
going to have a [__] I don't trust
nobody I don't even care if it's a
[__] go-kart I don't care if it's a
[__] bicycle I wouldn't trust nobody
driving me with a [__] thing so now
I'm going to have nobody in there are
you [__] [__] this is only
something that white people come up with
to be [__] stupid [__] nobody else
the chinks don't think about this
they're not thinking about this in
Africa nothing about this nowhere else
but [__] here white people what we
got a a whatever car you know to do what
to do what to do what cuz 20 of them are
going to [__] snap one day and
they're going to be in different cities
cuz they're all going to be on a
computer chip or something it's got to
be done with a computer I never thought
about that one yet so one day 600
[__] of these stupid cars are going
to be going nuts y on the different
Highway you need that zap out meanwhile
I got my [__] Cadillac dentree
that'll kill you if you tap into it you
you get see that's what I'm getting in
my next car forget the Subaru I'm
already driving around different
neighbors looking for an old cat like a
gas G I don't give a [__] at you want to
get my my Carmella had one of those yeah
not why not what year it doesn't matter
I don't even know years what do you
think I look around I don't know like
70s 8 80 I
1973 not DeVille but the other one
Cadillac DeVille not the CAC DeVille but
the Electra 225 I'm taking it back to
1975 [__] three four door electric
windows you hit somebody with one of
those [__] cars they ain't going to
live to tell the story there's no
kidneys there's no hips they're going
down heavy I would pay to see that going
up little let me tell you something you
hit me with one of those [__]
driverless cars you're blowing up right
there and I'm going to keep driving down
like nothing happened it's like one of
those bulletproof tanks they don't even
me dog those cars you can shoot at them
those Electra 225s I know the caddies
the caddies does it listen I know for a
fact you could shoot at those [__]
things when you got in the car accient
those things the windshield didn't break
it was like a 9in windshield to if you
were old and needed glasses you didn't
need them in that [__] car that's how
they made those cars what is it called
an Electra 225 for door get the [__]
brown with the tan interior leather
who's going to say something to you
you're living like Ricardo monm bom
before the
cap take a look at that [__] thing
what you think you're dealing with Lisa
a four door [__] those are nice
this is the real deal my dad had a caddy
I I borrowed it and then they stole the
The Hub Cap the like the cap cover they
they stole that [__] I don't want to get
I don't want to get
ginso but you got to get like old school
ginzo like not that one Capri classic
not none of those right there that black
one at the end oh [__] you see that
black one all the way at top top top top
way over to yeah first one all the way
right there boom let's see what that is
that's the good fell style who the [__]
you think you're dealing what is that
what car is that yeah that's a ship it's
it's what I put in I put in uh Electra
225 there it is right there [__]
beautiful yeah black on black white wall
look at no White Walls look at that
front tire is it a white wall or not oh
no it's not it's got a stripe the back
tire is different though that car right
there a shark you see that bumper right
there that's what it was made to look
like that's what America made to look
like that look at that car right there
you have nine feet between your face the
grill and the windshield nothing's
happening to you no airbag nothing's
happening to you nothing you got nine
[__] feet look at that you got
Shaquille o' you got a [__] what
engine do you have in there Lee [__] a
minivan let me check what engine do you
have in there it's an engine made you
put oil in that thing and you I mean you
know it's going to be expensive to
upkeep but ain't nobody going to [__]
with me once they once they put that car
on the road I go get an electric 225 I
don't even think it has an engine I
think there's just a dick under the hood
Buick right it's a Cadillac it's a
Cadillac okay Cubans love Cadillacs
always remember that there was more
Cadillacs in Cuba oh maybe it is a Buick
no Buick made it but it was a
Cadillac maybe it was a Buick wow is it
a Buick maybe it was a Buick goes yeah I
can't find anything I guess it's a Buick
all right let's go to
1973 Buick electr 2 let's see the
Wikipedia what the engine is on
it 72 let's see like that brown one get
that brown one right there look at that
[__] right there that's the two
door that's the boat I don't want the
boat that's the Ralph vanney Edition I
don't even know who Ralph Von is I don't
want to hang out with Ral
Ron let's see let me see what what
engine it is it's run by a whale dick I
guarantee it it's not even an engine
okay an engine
is 401 401 cubic yeah are you 6.6 V8 are
you [__] kidding me are you you
[__] kidding me it goes and it just
the more you go those horses Go Jack you
can hear those
horses diesel no it's just regular gas
yeah no I'm going to listen I blow miles
a gallon yeah I'll blow 80 bucks from
here to The Comedy Store but it's worth
every [__] time cuz if I hit you on
Lower Canyon nothing's going to happen
yeah nothing's going to happen nothing's
going to happen but going I don't even
think that car had seat belts you don't
need them they even tell you you don't
need them you don't even
need need seat belts what's the point
you don't need seat belts in this car
ain't nothing going to happen worst
thing that happens you break a rib or
you got to take a quick [__] that's it
nothing you'll [__] out the window that
back seat you could bang two BRS at the
same damn time at the same damn time did
it have the the uh bench front seat yeah
uh yes oh cool I love that bench front
seat that was something that was like
80s just 80s I remember sliding around
that front seat next thing you know you
date a girl she likes to get blow jobs
the seat bends that way I used to date a
girl that she couldn't figure out I
don't know why my seats maybe cuz you
suck 2,000 dicks in this [__] car and
you went this way you know what I'm
saying did you ever think of that we
took it to the Nissan dealer 2,000 dicks
that's my Memoir title she suck 2,000
dicks in that [__] car I'm not
kidding you're close to it and we had to
take the car to Nissan and Nissan
couldn't figure out why the seat was
crooked Engineers little Chinese dudes
with flashlights and [__] and I'm like
you guys stuck with the Nissan Bill no
do I look like the type of guy getting
stuck for a Nissan bill for the 2,000
[__] are you [__] crazy if I was
the first [__] in the she sucking my
dick maybe I'd pay half the seed bill
yeah you give a quarter of it yeah I'll
vacuum the seed I'll take all the dick
length off it and [__] but I'm the
[__] the seat was crooked from how
many Bull and I wish I was telling you a
lie wow I wish I was telling you good
for her hopefully she mastered her
technique hopefully it wasn't a
waste what are you going to do you know
things are bad all over you know what
I'm saying all right so you start com in
Syracuse and them yeah and then I moved
actually no I didn't start in Syracuse I
started in Boston when I was 8 I moved
there and I did improv for a few years
where did you do improv I did improv at
this place called the can tab Lounge oh
okay in in um it was in Cambridge oh
yeah C cuz they have the Improv Asylum
so I was wonder if you were there cuz I
I used to love that there was an Improv
Asylum there was improv Boston and then
the tribe was a group I was with and
then I started doing stand up from that
I was like this improv stuff is fun but
I I was like people just six people it's
hard to make it good man it's tough It's
a tough long version the short go [__]
yourself yeah go [__] yourself just grab
the mic and go for it Coop sucker you're
going to go up there with three idiots
give me a give us the name of a city I
could tell yeah that [__] Oklahoma like
oh okay Oklahoma now we got to play
[__] wizard I got to sit there and
get a headache for 30 minutes sh we did
we did musical improv so I had to like
grab finger symbols and [__] [__] out of
here got to sit there and get a headache
with a swamy hat on I need this [__] in
my [__] life it's too much man you
were never in improv tube Joy oh yeah
yeah I live for that get the [__] out of
here it was big when I first got into
standup in 91 where I got into standup
there was an improv TR and I went to
watch it and I liked what they were
doing but the broad drove me crazy
because she thought she was uh head burn
oh God but meanwhile she was just a
[__] [__] right and then she got
into stand up and she had this big
attitude and they made her a feature and
she died a million times so who the [__]
knows what happened to her I didn't like
it I didn't like the attitude of it I
didn't like the people that went to see
it it's a different thing it's a very
different the people who go see improv
it's a they're a weird animal and at the
io in in uh in uh Hollywood yeah they
would do an improv show on Fridays and
then put standups on them you should
have seen the look on their face when
they got a load of me because it's it's
real they they [__] they would [__]
their pants yeah I would go down there
Fridays at midnight just for a goof for
me and then go to the comy St do the
12:30 or the 12:45 right for a year I
went to improv Olympic as a goof right
because I and I couldn't
believe now again part of me is putting
it down but part of me is just I was in
disbelief of what I bumped in there like
I went there thinking something and it
was the complete opposite of what I
thought for starters everybody in there
was on a Visa card wow a dad Visa card
for a year to get your life together and
then become a improv guy every class I
had I went there to write
sketches at that time I heard sketch
groups sketch shows we're going to make
a comeback y so I was planning ahead of
the game so I paid 69 bucks and took
over 10 week sketch group I got to tell
you this after the fourth week I was
better than the teacher really yeah like
the teacher had written for one TV show
and all these little kids were rubbing
his feet and bringing them apples and
[__] I'm like this guy's a bum this
guy's a to the curb [__] bum this guy
ain't done what we do never and after
the fourth to fifth week and I'm
terrible at all that stuff I'm telling
you I was writing better sketches The
Improv troop was taking my sketches yeah
they were taking my sketches I never
wrote sketches before just Street [__] I
don't even know what the [__] I was
writing 3 minute sketches whatever the
[__] they are and they would grow them
out they took out of maybe 15 things I
wrote they probably took 10 of them wow
so I started going I started meeting the
kids and I would try to get together
with them to and they all had [__]
Audi what the [__] they all had BMWs
come on now they all lived in the
hills and here I am a comic work living
in a one bedroom fighting for my life
[__] and I got to talking to them and
then I started going to the iio and I
saw that the the the the people that
were even teaching
couldn't listen man I remember going to
Rooms to audition for movies and seeing
people that had seen another big movies
and [__] in my pants then the light bulb
would go off and I'd say wait a second
this guy did this this this and this but
guess what he hasn't done he never did
half time of a buffalo saber game yeah
and almost get [__] thrown at him from
the tub yeah
okay that built me up like that
destroyed my insights like they they did
this movie this movie this movie but
then they follow Paul M at The Comedy
Store at 12:45 four nights a week no
they didn't do that that's what they
didn't [__] do and what they didn't
do you can't take away from me no I'm
going to go in that room and [__] them
up and that's exactly what I would do
from that little confidence just that
little no matter I would think and you
when you go in there you think about all
your shortcomings you start thinking
about this guy came from a nice family I
came from a [__] family I did drugs I
went to prison but then that last life
hook has always saved me I go but this
guy let me tell what he hasn't [__]
done yeah he hasn't followed Don marrer
in the main room you know when you're
not going to do it and I see it all the
time and it burns me up a couple weeks
ago I went to that [__] Flappers down
there on a Monday Tuesday they had like
this actor from like all these
uh whatever
movies sudo comedy movies down there
trying to beedy you know you can tell
when he comes in with his actor [__]
you know Hi how are you like he's what
is it come on tell me who it is I don't
even know his [__] name I what's
those movies with the [__] dude from
s that live he he just played in [__]
whatever part two it was terrible with
he played the villain in that movie he's
old but everybody like he's like a
hundred but everybody tells you he's
[__] 33 oh Bill Murray no the other
dude Bill Murray the other [__] dude
from Chevy Chase no younger Young he's
the dude he did a he did uh the
basketball movie he does the reporters
movie will farell in the neighborhood
his cousins with will farell John C
Riley which one's will farell will
farell was on satday Al Will's Anchor
Man he's in those movies the guy I'm
talking about the sports guy John C yeah
will faroh like will faroh is one of
those dudes that's 50 but they keep
saying he's 32 yeah who is it come on
you know I don't know the actor's name
he's a in he's in the anchor man he's in
a bunch of those little stupid [__]
movies and he started getting into what
he look like I don't [__] know some
white dude and he comes in with his fake
attitude like hi oh you from here he's
Mak him believe that he cares like right
away nobody gives a [__] where you're
from I don't really give a [__] I'm just
hit to [__] rock the mic I don't give
a [__] you got Wings you got water do
the small chat chitat youat [__] the mic
and this [__] was going up there
talking all this [__] and I could tell
that he was watching me and when I got
off stage his face was just they never
see that it's like one time I was at I
think Lee was with me I was at the
[__] improv and what's his name was
that the other dude that's got the show
with the clown on [__] oh Zach was
there Zach [__] called me Zach called
Brody and said I never seen nothing like
that in my life because they weren't
laughing after [__] Sarah and Zach
you know those people at the Improv oh
my God Zach G KN has his hand our
evening has in May well [__] fat
little joyyy went up there I didn't have
him for like two two or three minutes
and then I just turned on and [__]
will Sarah I saw Sarah for a year after
that Sarah would always go that night
was amazing I never I didn't get to see
I heard about it I turned it around what
did you do whatever I just broke it down
for them said who the [__] do you people
think you are you know what the who the
[__] are you you're better than me what
are you going to do tomor you going to
go to a farmers market to get nutmeg
suck my dick you know I got a
three-year-old I just started throwing
Heat Ranon and all of a sudden when I
left there they were like and [__] I
hear somebody chasing me and it's Zach
he what the [__] was that and I go
that's stand up yeah that's stand up
that's what we're supposed to do not
supposed to go up there with you know
this guy's been in 20 movies Fu that
doesn't mean nothing when you got a
brick St you either going to put your
hands up cuz the cops are going to shoot
you you better start telling jokes [__]
and it's just amazing that we forgotten
that art like I'm old school I learn
from [__] prior man you go out there
and you [__] step on the gas and you
go and you say what's on your mind and
[__] it when you start holding back is
when you're slipping well there's three
old people if I say uh mud blood you
know it's not going to
work I'm dehydrating from the mushrooms
[__] it's good to stay hydrated I'm
glad it's not juice you need that water
you got another water in there for me
yeah I got two 22 [__] bers you're
about to have 20 left got like [__]
Le the man ofers nice we don't [__]
around here so now you're in Boston what
was next he's hanging on to his water I
was in Boston for three and a half years
all right then I was in New York for
nine almost 10 really yeah I was in New
York hitting the pavement banging it out
what clubs were you working I was doing
all of them and I ran my own shows I
used to bartend and I would run a show
at the bar I was bartending at have all
my friends come like I'd do the shift on
Tuesday then afterwards I would do the
standup thing
um and then I just ran shows I did my
own shows I would bark people in I did
that for years I would just ask any bar
I'm like hey can we do comedy here I
[__] asked everybody that's how you
have to do it that's the only and they
don't even know um yeah just I just need
a microphone and turn your light towards
the corner and we'll figure it out yeah
and I did a lot of road like just
[__] shows where I'm getting paid
dick not in Hot Dogs $50 nothing not
even breaking even you're coming out of
pocket you're driving six hours I would
do that you know i' do all that like
Jersey and all those like areas that
surrounded New York I'd do all the Roger
Paul yeah Roger Paul the $50 gigs
[__] come back to the office on
Monday and give you 45 hours I took my
commission out of there you're like what
the [__] yeah you're opening for places
you're going to weird I would call him
and he'd get me [__] gigs G [__] he
get you death gigs those those are the
most important ones those are the most
important ones horror ones he got me WS
Barry penl from Lind that's I love all
those games you know you do the Masons
like there's one place in Pennsylvania
huge like Masonic temple no I didn't do
that one I did the the the Connecticut
place with the animals in the room they
doing stage and they got [__] Bears
behind you it's like the
hunters they called me the last minute
the headline there and uh whenever I go
to New York I call Bookers and just go
listen I'm in town what you got what you
got they go we have nothing and by
Thursday night they're calling you with
the worst gig out of the whole lineup
like Friday night in Baltimore you're
going to pick up 225 but you you're not
going to get paid till you come to my
office Monday one time I came all the
way back and [__] Roger Paul kept
telling me that he didn't send me the
check I sent my friend Jimmy burkel he
worked over there and I said Jimmy just
go to this place and pick up the money I
don't even want to keep it I I would
tell you I didn't want the money I just
wanted the principal yeah he got me a
gig once on a Disney Bus going from C
caucus New Jersey to New York City 42nd
Street to tell jokes in the back of the
[__] bus have to snort and blow all
[__] night the night before that I
was in hoola hands in C caucus New
Jersey oh my God a oh my God you have no
[__] idea ladies and gentlemen when
you do comedy you do it wherever you can
you do comedy dog and the people who are
not doing this [__] I'm not even talk
you're not even ready for a cruise ship
cruise ship is right before you're going
to shoot yourself you go on a cruise
ship that's what you do then I'm talking
about early on they put us on a bus at
7:00 in the morning like good that
people were going to Good Morning
America those [__] and I'd be back
there talking about eating [__] and
[__] doing the night before what else
I got yeah he would tell me to work
clean [__] you and they would just stare
at me you did 15 minutes then something
else did 15 then you sat in the back of
the bus and then you just sat the back
of the bus amazing and they put more
people in and you do the same thing
going back to Jersey that was one
morning I mean and that you know that
just builds like that just builds like
scares you it's like you perform and you
do gigs like that and you you remember
that you remember those moments like you
like you can feel old cut like remember
that scar you can feel that scar tissue
and you're like yo who else has done
stuff like that the funny thing is that
when you doing that part of standup at
that time you're Al you're always
carrying a little bit of pain from your
past and now this new pain you're in
you're
encountering makes that old pain go away
or lessen a lot because it's not
really Lee and I have had a thousand
conversations about money and this and
that and I don't think Lee understands
that for 18 years before the podcast
what I went through what he went through
what a comic goes through I didn't go
through the same uh luck that a lot of
other Comics had I came here when I was
32 you're long in the tooth nobody wants
you from Montreal and you're at the
store banging it out you know and all
those years I still remember David tell
coming up to me in Miami and going I
wish I would have gone on as a feature
act I would have had a following now
because all those people really remember
you as a feature act then they they're
proud of you you become a headliner and
now they're proud of you it's like you
become a piece of them that they've been
there since day
one and I try to explain to people that
even this
podcast this podcast what made it easier
is our years of busting our ass and
awkward situations you know it's like me
going to jiu jitsu every day and going
listen today we're going to start with
you on top of me with your knee in my
[__] throat and I got to get out of
this that stand up every [__] day
stand up every day that stand up every
day a a 400 lb guy on top of you with
his elbow in your [__] throat Lee how
you feeling over there Lee's flying high
it's different it's different than
Edibles I don't feel like as like out
you want another mushroom you look like
a newborn baby yeah take another you
look good it's doing good for you you
look pregnant woman like
only in the face like the glow let's get
you a little nug look at this one this
is perfect for you this is his eyes
aren't open anymore Joe no that's the
goal of the show that's when you know
the show has come to a end is not open
when he's turning his head back like ow
and Benjamin the first 20 minutes his
eyes aren't even open every time I look
you want to wake up a little bit eat
this little stem right here this is a
special look like a Simpsons character
you're going to give him this thing yeah
we're all going to do a little no me and
Le are going to do another little sty
poop it smells weird what smells like My
toe from that funy to it does smell like
your toe yeah it does it does smell like
My toe Ian I don't know what your toe
smells like but I'm assuming your toe
smells like that I have a fungi toe and
when I cut the toenails off I sniff the
toenails it's horrible my dad has got
that his feet look like he looks like a
goddamn gargoyle from The Shins down he
looks like he belongs perched on a
building my front toe and the M the
second toe all the rest they're [__]
up right [__] up the first two I got
to sprinkle [__] in there why don't you
do Lerman or what I do I do every day
and the nails starting to crumble
crumbling the other day I got his
[__] blowtorch when they blow torch
the fungus on I went on Groupon and you
go to ventur Boulevard and some little
black lady with goggles on [__] takes
blow torch with cold air kill the liquid
nitrogen she starts blow torching your
toe you see the steam coming out of your
toe and all a sudden she's blowing cold
this and you don't feel it it hurts the
second time you're like ah it just burns
Aur kind of nice yeah Le eat that
[__] it's time it's time I already
ate mine two
times he over here eating them like
their chocolate chips that's how we do
here in the churs oh chew it get the
vitamins on with the Indians put
the please don't throw
up please don't throw up drink some
water CU oh you got the cap
on all right oh no it's a good Monday
night here on the church tonight people
you're going to be [__]
[__] 300 Mig of Gunda beans his face
has changed shape That's my boy he's a
[__] listen this kid's a je musom I
took three of them no no I know you did
I I've never done them I got to go I got
to go have a desert moment I can't give
her no mushrooms no well I'm going to go
have my desert 110 lb with a rock in her
pocket andu I will [__] my pants yeah
and that's the other thing it makes you
do take a [__] that's why I'm and I got
a big I got a fast system I'm like I'm
like a g goes right through you once
this thing cultivates in your stomach
you're going to be killing that [__]
bathroom Le you're going to be blowing
it up blowing it up diarrhea little
little are you okay Lee are you are you
having like an out of- Body Experience
right now Le's been having out of- body
experiences for four years now doesn't
you look like a newborn baby made him
smoke the hash out of the can it changed
this whole [__] life you look so
happy
lee it's not bad that's cuz you're
that's cuz you're here oh my God so now
how did MTV come aboard 10 years of
failure
they came knocking you showcased yeah I
just was you know they like keep their
eyes on on comics in in New York and you
know doing my thing working and I was
out there auditioning and doing all that
and I went in for it and it's just it
fit my personality cuz I just say how I
feel and that's the basis of the show
you know that the whole show is it still
on TV I don't think so no I left it for
the second season how many seasons were
I think four I left after two and it's
[__] up because people give like that
show
and like a lot of the shows like a bad
name but like even when I was growing up
like best week ever I was high schooler
it was what I it was fun people like to
talk [__] about anything they can talk
[__] about people are afraid people
don't like success and when something is
successful they got to chop it down
because they fear failure in themselves
it's just a human it's it's human nature
to do that and to be honest I I am
became fans of uh Doug Benson and I
think Pete Holmes was on the show too so
on the girl code no no no on uh best
week ever so it's just it was like the
same thing you never you never went in
for any of that stuff on like VH1 or MTV
one time they called me I didn't want to
do that do you ever get [__] for doing
kid movies no no one ever like looks
down I don't know I'd rather do that
than do a [__] the best week of yeah
that's how I always felt yeah you got
you got to do what you want to do one
time when I went to New York they asked
if I want to audition for I said no I
also did an audition for The Sopranos
the first time you didn't they [__]
the first first time my manager at the
time was worthless I'm in New York and
he calls me goes this is a show on HBO
Sopranos you would have been [__]
they looking for people like you and I'm
like I'm not going to New York and
dropping the tape off this manager was
terrible if he was good I would have
[__] dropped you you would have
gotten theall I went I wrote I read the
second season and didn't get it I read
for the detective because at first they
wanted the undercover cop to look like
[__] right so I went in there and then
I read for the part of bakala I read for
the part of Gigi wow he let me read he
liked me but I just could nail the rolls
I wasn't ready as an acent I was still
the paper would shake and [__] it's it
the is a [__] nerve racking
process it was for a while for me and
then I flipped that standup into it and
then that's smart then I treat it like
standup I put it I put the not the
dramatic side of the theater into it but
the dramatic side of stand up that's
smart I always won the
conversation I always do three reads I
control the audition I always do three
reads do one for them and one for me and
one together right let's see how it
sounds like together because right I
could tell you to go [__] yourself in 18
different ways yeah that's how I used to
look at those sheets I always read the
sheets and say what's he trying to say
cuz once you know what he's trying to
say you could say whatever the [__] you
want as long as I come to the final
conclusion and I hit my marks at every
level yeah so that's when I started
booking once I got I added the dramatic
side of standup not a
theater stand up what your that's your
core stand up has a dramatic side to it
yeah cuz you're tell well when you do
stand up like that you're telling the
truth so I I flipped that into it and it
became a lot easier in auditions and I
started ripping auditions apart to the
point where I didn't like the movie I
just wanted to book the job just to
prove my point I'll turn down the
[__] movie
because that's the shitty part is the
working unless it was a scale movie or
above right all those other ones I would
just go in there for practice that's
smart because that's that's that's the
only practice you can get is putting
yourself in those scenarios TV show same
thing I got it down to a science five or
six years you auditioned in this town
for you went in for the audition then
you went to the producer session then
you had to count nine out of 10 you had
to go to the producer session again so
early on I figured out I had to have
three auditions for them one better than
the other and a little bit more on each
time to push the envelope because they
could always tell you to back your speed
up but they can never tell you to give
more yeah so I I would always be a
little over the top just to contradict
the the director so the director would
have to tell me and it shows like a foul
Direction I got I was always good to F
Direction backwards not frontwards so
you figure these [__] things out and
pretty soon you're going in there it's
like picking off I was picking them off
everywhere Law and Order SUV I was just
pick them off special victim How I Met
Your Mother I destroyed them without
even reading a line my ball fell out the
pants ripped they did I didn't wear
underwear and my ball fell out and I
asked them what they say the ball Doom
there's a science to auditioning where
you don't even have to audition I've
been on three or four auditions I didn't
even read the sheet really just [__]
them up from you know I went to another
pilot Audition one time where the guy
was in he was a real hillbilly in Philly
you know like a real Yoko yeah so this
guy had us a you know he had a a pool in
his in his front yard that he was
filling up for his kid while he was
frying hot
dogs so who does that yeah you know what
I'm saying so I said [__] it I went with
with bikini underwear where with
sweatpants and the Lord was in my corner
I walked in when I walked in like give
us a minute they turned around right
there I dropped my
pants I took my jacket off and I had a
short shirt with my stomach coming out
the bottom so when they turned around
they were like that and I was and I may
believe I was cooking I go living like a
doctor H boom not it wasn't they wanted
the dude to say like you know hi I'm
over here having a great time come over
and people will look at him like who's
that [__] guy no if you come out of
your house and I look you straight in
the face and I got a hot dog and a fork
and I got a hose and I'm filling up a
pool and I got a thong on with no shirt
on and I'm looking you like you're
living like a doctor you're going to go
look at that crazy [__] he don't
even have a backyard he's got a four
front yard in his world this a four
front yard yeah in his world this a you
ever SE that's even a yard you see a
movie name 29th
Street no see if it's on what they have
on 29 Street 29 street is one of the
best films ever because it's Danny aello
as a dad and he raises Anthony lmoga and
he has to then they move but he had a
little front lawn like a typical Italian
4x4 and every day he'd be out there
watering talking about the Kentucky and
the whole family go Dad stop already
with the [__] lawn he had a 4x4 lawn
proud of but to his world it was [__]
he roll up his
pants 4x4 what's the big [__] drama
but in his world you know Danny I Ella
used to have a comedy club that
performed that in hobok there it is
right there dog that
movie is such a good it's called 29th
Street 29th Street put on the beginning
of it Le what the [__] you sitting there
you think I I made you go to it to sit
here [__] is it R up on that screen
let's see what we got here in the
beginning of this [__] make it move a
little Le you going to make me sit
here what is this what is
this go hit
it oh my God look at
movies oh that's right remember this
this is a true thing this is about a
lottery ticket and a guy who wins the
lobby but he didn't want to that's and
the guy and didn't want you know who
wrote this movie who Joe
pesh Joe pesh was the dude that says who
do you think you're dealing with Joey
bananas
in Midnight Run and he was also in 48
hours he was in the beginning of 48
Hours negotiating with Eddie Murphy
leave this oh okay leave this what the
[__] in the beginning he's negotiating
with Eddie Murphy in the truck that's
Joe PES Joe PES sold this movie wow this
is a [__] and it's a true story I
worked with Joe PES I he was in uh in uh
New Orleans with with Stallone when I
shot that boxing movie and he gave me a
big hug he still remember me Joe p is a
great dude he's been in a [__] that
look Joe garola look it click it Le
right there from here yeah right there
Tony no no no right there click it open
it up let it
play Let It play look at this
[__] fast l I took his acting [__] uh
class at UCLA for 200 bucks my wife gave
it to me for my birthday we could barely
pay rent she paid 200 bucks for the
acting seminar by this guy that's sweet
this is why he also cast Hannibal he
cast [__] oh [__] he cast Godfather 2
he cast sleepers he cast Donnie Brasco
this dude's a [__] Frank pesh was one of
executive producers see if he starts in
the beginning let's
see
look at how old these movies
are this has to be yeah I saw this one
night by mistake I cried everybody who
I've turned this movie and it's on once
a year on that Chicago channel WGN WGN
are you happy
now are you happy God you had to do this
to me you weren't happy leaving me alone
H are you now fast forward this little a
little bit I'll tell you the way cuz he
gets arrested right there no no keep
going back a little bit keep going back
little keep going back keep going back
keep going back keep going back right
there right there
the this is a tremendous [__] movie
if you want to cry like already
I'm [__] God damn
it look at Danny
aell
this is way before I do the right thing
guys if you watch this at home if you
want to [__] cry you watch this
goddamn movie cried when he saw us for
the first time my brother my sister
me
a with the hot
dog be late 20 minutes from here to
Radio
City you don't want nothing come on
let's walk such a let's go eight blocks
right yeah but we're going to see
student prce come
[Music]
on when I was younger my dad used to
always seem like this giant to me this
this guy who knew everything about
everything are you crying Joey oh yeah
no I'm I'm more High than crying what's
that what's that say well that says uh
today is President Eisenhower's birthday
I want get my name up there well I
wouldn't want to have it any other way
Frankie but only great people get their
names up there how can I get my name up
there I me you know you got to do
something big
big very very big hey Pop how look at my
name up
there this
big I guess have we something to make
his did you ever do his Club in home you
so he doesn't feel like a jerk for
having you and I figured if I could get
my name up on that building at least I
could have left some kind of Mark on the
world now in my neighborhood like two
ways to make it one's the right way and
the other way is the fast way and I got
to tell you the fast way looked pretty
attractive to me as a kid wow look at
that what's the matter keep forward fast
forward this l
two he fast fallowing this look you got
Dr Dre not not that much not that much
he gets a little older this is
hysterical
[Music]
right he just took his earphones off and
he wants to quit [__] he's like I'm done
you want to smoke some
pot
really because you need to calm that
Savage in especially when my dad lost
his truck his eyes are a little more
open oh no they're not he's all right he
needs a milkshake we'll get him the
milkshake it'll be
fine milkshake milkshake one milkshake
see one milkshake one milkshake you'll
be fine trust me that milkshake such you
straight oh milkshakes when when has a
milkshake not set you straight yeah it's
true a milkshake straightens you right
the [__] out shut this [__] off let me
give you some shout outs and we'll get
everybody the [__] out of here weu up on
mushrooms he's seeing devils and [__]
I'm going have to put lead Zeppelin on
and
[__] [__] No Quarter in this
[__] oh my God now you get on
this fu Girl Code you're on there for
two years what made you move to LA um E
E network plucked me from MTV okay and
uh it was a very it was hard at the end
with MTV everything got very contentious
so uh I chose e over MTV and I did an
overall deal with them for a year trying
to make shows but Chelsea was doing her
thing on Stern talking crap and uh you
know um Joan passed away Joan Rivers
passed away and the head of e got fired
so all these transitional things
happened while I was with the network
trying to build a show and so I sort of
was under rug swept it was a great
learning experience for a year I was
working my ass off I shot a ton of
Pilots they were very you know uh
accepting but it just they were plug in
too many holes so it wasn't you know the
the best timing for me but I learned a
lot and shot a lot of pilots and worked
my [__] ass off and now I'm just a
free agent just out there on the road a
lot doing
standup why you smiling you're smiling
at I'm just smiling because I know
you're liking it I love it I know you're
out there it gets tough at times it gets
lonely it's it's hard for a woman it's
hard for a [__] man you know it's
hard for everybody I'm not even saying
nothing in the wrong way it's just hard
no it's hard it is I've had a couple
female comans tell me it ages you it
every you know every comic has a
different take on it but we all know
it's like cigarettes it's like Chinese
food It's Like Cocaine it's like
McDonald's we know but it ain't that bad
for you no it's not that bad for you but
it's it ain't that bad for you so it's
all [__] I mean I feel very lucky I
feel very fortunate to be doing this at
this age and still being relevant and
cracking jokes and [__] around with
kids half my age I I love it for me
that's what makes me get on the planes
you know I can't
do every week and do the world tours I
used to do but I could do uh 24 20 weeks
a year and that's good that's good you
know take December off why [__] kill
yourself after the first week of
December there's no reason to go out
there it's all Christmas parties and
[__] after Christmas that week I told
you if it's local if you're going to go
cross country don't think about it don't
tell them no I'm not going you ever see
those people Christmas time you get your
feet up and they're at the airport with
and you're like look at those [__]
it's worse when you're one of those
[__] you're like why traveling
during that time it's after stress after
the 12th of December there's no drowning
I'll see you January 20th yeah you've
worked enough gives you six weeks and it
gets away that cold weather out of the
way which you don't travel during that
sh you know well it's a great weekend
the first weekend after the New Year
send your mother send your mother to go
with a [__] bikini with a wig to
dance down there see how good it is yeah
see how good it is so have fun down
there that second third week of January
eases up the money eases up people start
getting their credit card bills they've
been in the house for three [__] an
now you start going out but they go out
New Year's weekend the force people 25
two drink men leave them at home yeah
leave them at home I don't want to
attack my peeps like that they're
[__] family these people go to shows
they are so I don't really want they're
broke they're still [__] recovering
from the holidays you're going to show
up with a big dick hi I'm here crap of
stupid jokes then you didn't sell this
you didn't sell as many tickets as you
did last time yeah cuz I was there a
year ago right with the same [__]
stupid jokes the same Persona get me out
of there for 18 months make them want me
back let them see 10 people yeah that's
all these variables you know I've been
here for years and when I got here
gersch had the majority of the great
Comics Slayton the the the Jewish chick
the Wendy LeMans the [__] Slayton the
[__] Joe Rogan they had Dave
Chappelle they had all those Comics at
the time Pablo Francisco everybody was a
gers and one thing I noticed with their
work schedules and at the end of the
week at after three years you burn up
and now I can't really put them back out
there I'm like the mafia I want you to
pay me every month a little bit yeah I
don't want all your money just give me
five points of Your Action I'd rather
milk it and be around for 7even eight
years Ralphie May I feel a little
burnout One Last Comic Standing in 200
[__]
five Ralphie May goes 45 weeks a year
since 2005 that's just that's you're
asking to you're killing yourself you're
killing yourself you're killing yourself
it's taking care of yourself it's
cleaning out your mind you know having
another hobby you know for me people get
mad at me oh you come to Pittsburgh do
my podcast
no when I do comedy I do comedy what's
your other Hobby and podcasting yeah so
Monday and Wednesday I do podcast I
would I do one set T tomorrow night I do
I tape that for R but usually Tuesdays I
go to Flappers of the store one set it's
not my focus my focus is this you put
you got to put energy into Wednesday as
soon as we say check it out it's over
that's it I don't even think a
podcasting no more if I do your podcast
like I said last week you got to pick me
up take me to the location that's an
hour half hour I got to meet your buddy
smoke a joint seem interested now you
took two and a half hours out of my day
and I got two shows on a Friday yep it's
smart now I'm bombing the first show
because I I talk [__] for you for three
[__] hours about nothing somebody
that's not going to listen to this
anything you know it's why am I doing
this yeah it has nothing to do with my
mission here yep so when I rock I rock
you got to save the energy for you and
when I roll I [__] roll tell
them Lisa sucker
I want to thank my main man chome Moses
and his beautiful wife they brought me a
CD lindan Miller and Steve my man showed
up heavy duty Mark Thomas my man from
North Bergen Danny ban kulo Don Wrangler
John Harris happy birthday to Bob lingis
his mom Primo PCO on 155th Street and
Greeno
Roo making it [__] happen over there
so where you got the paperwork for me
Lee what are you doing
how you doing look at the shape of Le
Lee Lee is the color of a peach Lee is
on [__] fire his face looks like a
fruit I went to the beach and I put
sunscreen on three times in 3 hours and
I'm just so white that nothing I just
can't go anywhere you are pretty pale
yes that's very I'm olivy compared to
you so what's your next plan Jess what
are you looking to do promote your own
show produce your own show now yeah I'm
I'm writing three different shows just
to get out there and and pi him and sell
them and I'm taking you're going to be
proud of me you ready yeah I'm taking 8
weeks off of the road8 weeks and what
are your plans I'm taking yeah after
Philadelphia I have maybe seven weeks
off I have two weeks off in June I go to
Vegas with Joe I'm doing the eighth with
Joe that's one night I come right back I
go to surgery Monday July July maybe
I'll go and check July 8th on a on a
Friday night before UFC trying to catch
you guys Monday I come Sunday Saturday I
come back don't even stay for the fights
yeah I'm with my family Sunday Monday I
go over to the hospital they break my
nose they clear out the old Coke rocks
and I [__] I'm Breathing by [__]
two weeks later I'll do the ice house
and then I do
Denver Oklahoma casino and I do
something else Nashville
Nashville then I got like three weeks
off then I go to New York and Austin
then I got two weeks off and I go to I
need my time I need my time my family I
need my time to live my life I like the
road I love performing I love taking
pictures I don't sell shirts I just hang
out with people
afterward but I you have to live and I
know that the more towns I do the
quicker my exit from what I'm doing then
the club start calling you and say
listen only 10 people showed up we want
you to come in here for $3 in a [__]
dream and that's what a lot of comedians
are living through now you know for the
guys that are selling tickets you have
to be very grateful because it's a short
window yeah and the other Comics are
there's a lot of comics who are't
selling tickets yeah and they still go
in there and they [__] cling it up
you know I always use David tell people
don't go want to go see David tell no
more he's probably the best comic he's
one of the best Comics out there so just
because you're not popular doesn't mean
you're good meanwhile you're wasting
your [__] hard ear money but want to
see some [__] fake [__] comic from
some stupid [__] TV show that's never
done stand up in his life but David tell
is starving up there in Long Island not
really starving but nobody's going to
see him he's a great talent because we
have Trends and we have who's hot who's
not hot pop culture pop culture and the
industry pushing out the I do the same
thing with music I've said it a thousand
times I don't want to go see Sabbath and
Rudy SEL sat there and said why not
they've been doing it for 40 years now
how good are they and if you look at
Sabbath if you look at [__] uh all
the Sabbath tapes on YouTube it's not
Azie that sounds spectacular it's
Sabbath that sounds it's Tony iomi and
Giza Butler who aie sounds like he's
screaming through a hemorrhoid storm
Azie sounds like [__] aie you know
and you don't know who's singing last
night I watched those American Music
Awards I watched bits and pieces I was
sitting there trying to kill time I just
want listen you're old you don't know
what's really happening I was
embarrassed for America last night you
were I was really embarrassed well
Britney Spears is lips sing you look at
Britney Spear she sold 140 M PR obvious
it was pretty obvious she sold 140
million albums somebody bought these
albums now I'm not here to criticize
nobody but I don't know if you people
know this the studio she's Madonna Jr
she is what somebody didn't know all
those years is Madonna couldn't sing and
she proved it last night did you hear
her singing Purple Rain oh my God it's
[__] hardd it was [__] hard see if
you find Madonna Madonna Purple Rain
want meie oh we're definitely getting
taken off YouTube who gives a [__] do
you want me to help you type it you got
to see this [__] should should I search
Madonna mad mad and Stevie won the
Prince Tribute wait till you [__] see
this thing and it just wasn't her
Justin Bieber was lip-syncing because
they move they're doing that same rhy
Nation they're all doing the same Rhythm
Nation I'm told I told my wife Rhythm
Nation came out in what ' 92 it's 2016
you're still going out with there with
that same you know 16 dances flying
through the [__] air I just want to
see you sing and see your lips fcking
move where's my money going where the
[__] is my money going got up on a
[__] thing like a witch with fire
like some f i don't need that she she
looks like me she's 80 lbs overweight
pink that she wants to be an acrobat
give it a [__] breather then that
Adele who's also another [__] fake
she can't sing give a breather is this
it here we got to play this go about
Adele yeah what about Adele that [__]
cheeseburger eating [__] go go Le wait
till you see this [__] oh God I'm so
wait till you hear her [__]
voice look at what she looks like for
stars she looks like a muppet look at
her look at her
Nothing
[Music]
Compares nothing compares to you Prince
wrote this song look at her look at
her now I love Madonna I bought the
first three [__] arm I love like a
virgin but a lot of a lot of people got
a big surprise when they went to see it
she can't sing it was all [__] Studio
thing want to see you dancing
look at look look look look at are you
[__] crazy and you got Stevie Wonder
he's like why am I here look at he looks
like Marlon Brandon Apocalypse Now look
at I don't even know where the [__] he's
at he's like I didn't even like
[__] princ that little
[__] wormy [__] most of all
thank you horri nelon turn this [__] off
horrible oh my God that's so bad what
why are we applauding mediocrity because
that's what we're doing now this was so
so [__] bad that's what's happening
in this culture everything is so bad and
we're clapping our hands and we're like
yay and what I'm trying to say is if the
more you you know the more you go to
these Captain Marvel movies the more
they're going to keep supporting that
monster machine stupid [__] they're
killing everything and you sit there and
go who goes to see these [__] things
anyway what cities are you going to next
are you [__] sexy Savage you I don't
even know where the I'm I'm done for a
while man I'm done
you're done you're here for the next
weeks I'm going to be I'll be in Long
Island at the end of July I'm going to
be in um Mohan Sun the first few days of
September but other than that for the
summer I'm I'm buckling down and I'm
writing the shows I really want to work
on CU I want to create my you know I'm
going write my own [__] do something I
want to do I'm not chasing I'm not out
there to to be rich I'm not out there to
be famous I'm out there just to to bring
my truth to people and hopefully they
want it you know I don't want to be up
there telling some dumbass jokes because
people you you know what I mean like I
want to speak my truth I don't want to
be a people
pleaser I I just want them to like the
way I present it I don't want to present
it in a way that I think other people
are going to pay me for does that make
sense or am I really [__] high no no
no both both right now we're working on
two [__] elements let me wrap this up
here listen man I've been trying to get
you on for a while we were [__] up
you you always welcome here your family
you did great toight I had a great time
talking to you I love you too our first
sponsor is on it always on [__] point
you understand me Alpha Brain shroom
Tech the hemp Force protein those are
the ones I dig and if they're [__]
doing wonders for me and I'm a [__]
old man could you imagine what they'll
do for you shroom Tech when I fly the
immune takes care of me today before
Jiu-Jitsu I blasted a hemp Force protein
with a banana and some water and some
ice
cubes
32 grams of protein you digest it nice
it's that hemp [__]
thing give it a shot I'm going have to
try that [__] out they get an immune
boost too they have a thing when you fly
they have shroom Tech immune and sport
sport gives you more endurance it's
those mushrooms that are grown up in
high altitude so they expand your lungs
quad quadricep thank you Lee look at
them look at you [__] Knowledge from
the W look who woke up look who's
dropping Knowledge from the womb you for
another mushroom now why you keep doing
nothing because we're just eating little
ones like a cute fetus I had to I had to
open up a Word document and the numbers
are all jumbled up okay look at his
little left hand it's all [__] you
see him he's got the he's got like he's
got the hook next thing you know he's
going to go with that guy and kill his
girlfriend oh [__] Ting Ting Ting
Ting anyway go to hit.com right now and
press in hit itly Church c h u r CH and
get 10% off your first daughter always
all right your first daughter your first
order order order and it gets delivered
right to your door shroom Tech shroom
Tech sport Alpha Brain with a money back
guarantee if you want weights and kettle
bells I can't do nothing for you
there anyway let me explain something to
you he
uh let me talk let me talk to you
[__] all right oh my God this
is hilarious I'm over here thinking I
got think about what the [__] you we two
lbs of mushrooms you ate you ate F you
ate a human how much do we eat a human
size amount of like a whole human worth
of mushrooms you literally every time I
look at you you look like the different
phase of
life like the younger phases for you
were like a you look like a pregnant
woman in the face and now you look like
a
fetus anyway let me [__] do this [__]
and we'll talk all night I tell you one
hobby I was trying to do is get to Wine
couple years ago I don't know nothing
about wine I want to get into the wine
the problem is I don't know nothing
about it I tried cabinet and Pinos but I
couldn't find anything that I liked at
the store then I tried this club W these
people approached me and and they said
take a look at I said No at first but I
went online it's a wine club that gives
you wine
recommendations based on what you like
to eat or drink they've got a a thing
with that you a test a little simple six
question pallet quiz that ask you
questions like how do you take your
coffee or do you like berries Club W
that matches you with the wine that
you're guaranteed to love because it's
tailored to your unique taste and uh not
only that they deliver this wine to your
house it's great wine it's very cheap
it's fast like I ordered some a couple
weeks ago and it's there in like 3 days
what not even and it's like I got a I
got a really good Pino Noir it was like
one of the fancy ones and I got some
other like some other white ones for for
Paula and they're great they're great
and they're and if you do four boxes I
mean four four bottles sorry uh they
they cover the shipping that's not a bad
deal but what makes Club W different
okay it's delivered straight to your
door we send you wine that is
personalized see your pet taste through
our pet quiz our recommendations become
even more personalized with every bottle
you rate we work with top wine makers
and Growers from around the world
directly to make our own wine and we cut
out the middleman that's where the
saving goes on to you our bottles are
$13 and they would normally retail for
20 plus you choose the type and the
quality of bottles the quantity of
bottles with no membership fee or
cancellation fee and there's 100%
satisfaction guarantee all right we also
partner up with local artists to develop
wine labels the unique Works art so do
yourself a favor right do me a
favor go to Club W so okay right now
Club W is offering my listeners $2 off
your first order when you go to clubw
docomo again right right now Club W is
offering listeners Church of What's
Happening Now $20 off your first order
when you go to
club.com Joey and it even gets better I
know you all hate paying for shipping so
Club W will actually pay you your
shipping on orders of four bottles or
more so take something off your to-do
list just go to Club
w.com Joey to get 20% off your first
order right now $ $20 off your first
order right now again that's Club
w.com Joey it's going to be the best
choice you've made in
years I want to thank Club W I want to
thank an.com I want to thank my main
girl JZ Palo for coming on and just
talking [__] not [__] trying to
promote dumb [__] she was a [__]
great guest try my man Lisi for always
being a soldier he's over there nodding
and [__] foaming on himself he fell
asleep in the middle I know please he
fell asleep a couple times
yes you were you were [__] drooling
you saw you making those no you were
making those [__] mouth yeah he was
how many tacos you going to eat tonight
how many potato tacos you going to eat
tell me the truth milkshake milkshake
what' you eat for dinner a turkey
sandwich what youa done I had some mac
and cheese mac and cheese I made mac and
cheese oh aren't you [__] lucky did
she dop it up yeah it was really good
what you open up with with like the
cheddar cheese that Terry did and then
the breadcrumbs oh [__] that's all you
ate nothing else no steak no piz no
steak piz all nothing no I didn't have
any steak you just carbed it up the
chicken breast I knew it's going to be a
heavy night it's going to be a heavy
night that's right it's going get
heavier [__] all right you Church
[__] I'll see you Wednesday
night 8:00 P.M we'll be back I'll be at
the uh Funny Bone
in Nebraska are you [__] kidding me
or what the Omaha Funny Bone June 10th
and 11th and I'm at the philad IIA
[__] helium 2 weeks later
figure it out like the 25th or some [__]
I don't have the dates inched in my
[__] brain I love you J [__] you Joe
I was looking at you for the first time
like [__] J is beautiful you work
with these girls the sisters you don't
look at them you start looking at
cheekbones and [__] like Jesus [__]
Christ you're my brother I hear you
that's why I love you baby girl thank
you very much for coming on the church
thank you guys for listening I'll see
you guys Wednesday at 8 stay black Lee
kick that [__] [__] me
[__] that was fun that was
[Music]
a
beat down brother check it out I'm about
to throw down diing hand and [__] that
had your toe down a little city chilling
in the no Bay needless to say My boys
don't play fool y side and you know how
the song goes in the back siing purple
CH go don't look for trouble but it
always seems to find us 40 gripping
pantties sipping and it seem to behind
us quick La one blow KO hit the road to
the next episode in The Saga of a few
fellas oh what the hell I guess I better
tell you it's Friday night I got a brand
new kit on I the he for me to get bent
on hit the C called to pick up ML a w
back to the
[Music]
hotel at the doing fight work Johnny Z
had his hand up on Min skirt the lot in
the corner started the flirt and I knew
that when she saw me baby doll was going
to Dr me set for the night so I took her
to my ride grab my Mickey and my B and I
met her outside who ride roll striking
through to be seen Alexis 400 turn the
triple go Z acid in my bottle so I got
to get some more put the pedal to the
metal back to the LI sto cuz you know
what I mean when I'm feeling kind of
funky a sick honky straight going donkey
money in my sock Jimmy in a glove laying
in the L say I'm about to make good love
and Burn Rubber up the block back to the
jelly I got to get some new car new car
new car
[Music]
new oh no could it be I just got a page
in a brad want to do me hooked it up
told her meet me at the hotel she had a
friend with her so I call TL swoop me up
Sally wanted me dick and my so try make
it real
quick oh yeah I jumped in the air train
but wait a minute we got to hit the sto
man I got to get some gum and some Tic
Tacs two t can and a packet of black
jacks we got the goods now we're heading
for the ho down there goes a Telly so
fell one just slow down parked the ride
in in front like a sick one just in case
we got to bust a quick one lock the low
let's go look for like 118 but lay low
cuz I really don't want to be seen is
this the oh yeah that's the right one I
got the black right and you got the
white one so hit the light man I just
might man try and throw this thing all
night in get her so sprung that she'll
drops the mail so I can cut tur and hit
another
[Music]
hotel
he